c'est là et sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect à la
fois du temps de parole et des uns et
des autres et je donne immédiatement la
parole au président Patrick canaire pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci président madame la Première
ministre en préambule à ma question je
rappelle un principe intangible
la violence ne peut en aucun cas être
une réponse à mécontentement social ou
politique aussi au nom de mon groupe je
condamne l'agression dont a été victime
Jean-Baptiste trogneux et lui apporte
notre total soutien
je manifeste le même soutien à Yannick
Morel mère de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins qui
a subi intimidation harcèlement et
agression autant d'actes un qualifiables
envers un élu de la République qui ne
faisait qu'exercer son mandat il mérite
également mes chers collègues le respect
le soutien indéfectible du Sénat
oui mes chers collègues un vent mauvais
souffle sur notre pays un maire de
France a dû céder devant la menace la
violence la haine l'a emporté sur la
bienveillance la force l'a emporté sur
le droit la multiplication des pressions
des agressions envers les élus et
quantifiables et documentés les élus
locaux et plus particulièrement les mers
sont les fondations de la République
quand une de ces fondations s'écroule
comme avec la démission de Nedic morrez
c'est tous les 10 fils qui est fragilisé
l'audition émouvante de ce dernier ce
matin par la commission d'une des lois
du Sénat c'est transformé en
réquisitoire contre les services de
l'État tant ont été révélés de graves
défaillance c'est un échec madame la
Première ministre pour ne pas dire un
désastre dont il faut tirer toutes les
conséquences dès aujourd'hui
Saint-Brévin c'est aussi le signe d'une
résurgence des violences de l'extrême
droite depuis plusieurs semaines ces
actes de terrorisme intellectuel et
physique se sont multipliées pour
empêcher les mères qui le veulent de
prendre part des demandeurs d'asile
madame ma première ministre on ne peut
mettre sur un pied d'égalité l'extrême
droite et d'autres formes de
contestation l'extrême droite que ce
soit au sein de nos institutions ou dans
le cadre d'action clandestine et
l'ennemi mortel de notre démocratie
l'État ne peut rester larmes aux pieds
face à ces menaces allez-vous engager ce
combat pour défendre les élus de la
République
[Applaudissements]
on vous répond de la parole de madame la
Première ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
S
semaine Yannick Morel le maire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins a été victime
d'une campagne insupportable de
harcèlement en lien avec un projet
d'implantation d'un centre d'accueil
pour demandeurs d'asile dans sa commune
et fin mars son domicile a été incendié
alors oui ces actes sont inadmissibles
derrière chaque élu agressé c'est la
République qui est visée
avec chacun de vous et en évitant toutes
polémique monsieur le Président kaner je
partage le choc et l'indignation face à
cette situation comme face à chaque acte
de violence contre les élus en
présentant sa démission Yannick Morel a
pris une décision difficile en son âme
et conscience nous ne pouvons que
regretter qu'il était conduit à faire ce
choix et naturellement nous le
respectons je le recevrai tout à l'heure
avec l'Association des maires de
Loire-Atlantique et l'Association des
maires de France mon objectif est de
l'écouter et de lui exprimer le soutien
de mon gouvernement les mers sont en
première ligne sur le terrain ils sont
les premiers témoins de la montée de la
défiance dans notre société nous devons
les protéger nous devons protéger tous
les élus et pour y parvenir le
gouvernement s'engage le ministre de
l'Intérieur les préfets et les forces
les forces de l'ordre sont mobilisées le
droit pénal a été renforcé pour
permettre aux associations d'élus et aux
collectivités de se constituer partie
civils à plusieurs reprises le ministre
de la Justice a demandé au procureur des
réponses fermes rapides visibles contre
les atteintes aux élus et nous sommes
prêts à travailler avec vous comme avec
l'Assemblée nationale pour renforcer les
sanctions pénales contre les violences
envers les dues et nous voulons aller
plus loin depuis des mois nous préparons
des mesures nouvelles que la Ministre
chargée des collectivités territoriales
Dominique Faure présentera tout à
l'heure il s'agit de renforcer le lien
entre les mers et la justice de mieux
prévenir les violences et d'accompagner
encore davantage les élus c'est un sujet
auquel je tiens particulièrement et que
j'avais eu l'occasion d'évoquer avec
l'ensemble des associations d'élus le 12
avril dernier mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il n'y a pas de démocratie
sans respect des élus pas de démocratie
sans sécurité pour les élus avec vous
tous avec le gouvernement nous
continuerons à agir je vous remercie
quelques secondes
merci président madame la Premier
ministre les élus de la République
demandent pas de compassion il demande
de l'action et qu'il puisse agir
eux-mêmes et quand madame Dominique
Faure évoque la création d'un centre
d'analyse pour savoir ce qui se passe
dans le pays permettez-moi de vous dire
que nous le savons depuis bien longtemps
que tout est quantifié et quantifiable
et que nous demandons simplement que la
réflexion qui menée notamment au Sénat
puisse être appliquée pour protéger les
élus de la République
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Véronique
Guillotin pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Madame Monsieur
Madame la Ministre avec mes collègues
Jean-François Husson et Véronique del
Fabro je vous interpelle sur les faits
qui se sont déroulés samedi à Villerupt
en plein centre-ville à deux pas d'un
parc pour enfants une fusillade a eu
lieu sur fond de trafic de drogue le
bilan humain et la violence des faits
ont profondément choqué et bouleverser
les habitants cinq blessés trois dans un
état grave tout s'était âgé entre 17 et
30 ans mes pensées vont bien sûr aux
victimes à leur famille à toutes les
villes ruptiens et toutes les villes
ruptiennes à qui nous devons apporter
des réponses tout le monde est choqué
mais personne ne semblait surpris or ce
point de vie avait pignon sur rue depuis
des mois les tarifs des stupéfiants sont
encore inscrits sur les murs à côté
d'une fresque d'enfants ce drame mais
effectivement lumière le débat récurrent
du sous-effectif chronique de la
circonscription de police longuyville
rue il manque à ce jour 15 policiers au
moins vendredi le ministre de
l'Intérieur a annoncé l'ouverture de 11
postes si cette nouvelle part d'une
bonne intention il y a peu de chance que
ces posts soient pourvus par défaut
d'attractivité du territoire madame la
ministre ce qui s'est passé est grave
suite aux échanges que nous avons eu ces
derniers jours avec le cabinet je salue
l'arrivée d'un escadron de gendarme
mobile dès cet après-midi à Villerupt
pour autant à moyen terme et afin de
remonter les effectifs comptez-vous nous
affecter des policiers en sortie d'école
enfin un dernier regret la ville
ruptiale que je suis n'a jusqu'ici pas
réussi à convaincre les élus locaux de
la nécessité de se saisir de tous les
outils contra local de santé police
municipale
vidéoprotection je crois que c'est tous
ensemble pas en opposant les uns aux
autres c'est tous ensemble en laissant
tomber les idéologies que nous ferons
reculer la délinquance la mise en place
d'une réunion de concertation locale en
urgence s'impose il y va de la sécurité
et de la tranquillité des habitants je
compte sur le ministre car il est encore
temps d'enrayer cette spirale infernale
j'en suis convaincu
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales
madame Faure merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Guillotin oui ce qui
s'est passé est très grave vous l'avez
rappelé samedi dernier dans la soirée
les effectifs de police intervenaient
pour plusieurs coups de feu tirés dans
le centre-ville de ville Europe ville
Rupt en Meurthe et Moselle sur place les
policiers découvrent cinq blessés par
balle dont trois sont en urgence absolue
d'après les premiers éléments cette
tentative d'homicide serait en lien avec
le trafic de stupéfiant dans le cadre
d'une recrudescence de la violence entre
bande rivale pour le contrôle de ce
trafic quelques heures après l'effet
l'auteur présumé de la fusillade a été
interpellé par la police judiciaire de
Metz assistée par la BRI je tiens ici à
remercier tous les policiers pour leur
mobilisation et leur action rapide et
efficace sur instruction de Gérald
Darmanin escadron de gendarmerie mobile
soit 70 gendarmes vous l'avez dit a été
envoyé sur place des hier ils seront en
place au moins jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine pour la circonscription de
police dont dépend il Rupt le
l'Intérieur annonce ouverture vous
l'avez dit aussi de 11 postes par
ailleurs 44 nouveaux postes seront
ouverts sur l'ensemble du département
meurt et Moselle nous constatons que le
trafic de drogue touche aujourd'hui les
villes de taille moyenne comme la vôtre
c'est pourquoi nous devons lutter contre
ce trafic à tous les niveaux je pense à
l'excellent travail réalisé par les
policiers des Yvelines qui ont effectué
une saisie records de deux tonnes 5 de
cannabis pour une valeur marchande de 20
millions d'euros il y a seulement
quelques jours je sais que tous les élus
concernés sont particulièrement
mobilisés sur le sujet et
particulièrement vous les sénateurs
hussons chacun del Faro et vous-même
madame la sénatrice pour cette raison et
vous l'avez indiqué le préfet va réunir
l'ensemble des élus concernés dans les
plus belles délais cette réunion est
d'ores et déjà programmée je vous
remercie
quelques secondes madame Guillotin
oui quelques secondes pour dire
qu'effectivement quand on voit un tel
drame et qu'on entend dans la rue dire
que ça n'étonne en fait quasiment
personne je crois qu'il y a des vrais
leçons à prendre l'État doit assumer ses
responsabilités l'État ne doit pas
défaillir mais ses mains dans la main
état et les locaux que nous devons
travailler et faire reculer cette
délinquance merci la parole est à notre
collègue Renan Dantec pour le groupe
écologique solidarité territoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Yannick mauvaise a démissionné
et il ne reviendra pas sur sa décision
le maire de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins est
ainsi devenu depuis quelques jours le
symbole des difficultés des élus locaux
à exercer leur mandat non plus seulement
apporter d'engueulade mais bien de
calomnie d'agressions aussi et dans ce
cas d'un attentat criminel qui aurait pu
le tuer sa femme et lui il y a une
mauvaise n'a pas démissionné par peur ou
par lassitude il a démissionné parce que
l'État ne l'a pas protégé Yanni Maurice
depuis l'incendie de sa maison le 22
mars était devenu le symbole du courage
de l'élu républicain celui qui assume
sans faiblir la tâche que lui a confié
l'État en l'occurrence le déménagement
d'un centre d'accueil pour demandeur
d'asile un cada déjà installé sans
problème dans la commune depuis 2016 il
est en tribune et c'est d'abord à ce
titre que nous lui rendons hommage il
tenait bon face à la haine de l'extrême
droite et des sbires Éric Zemmour
monsieur le ministre qu'il n'y ait pas
de faux débat nous condamnons tous ici
toutes les violences politiques et je
veux associer à l'expression de notre
dégoût face à ce cas subi à l'île
Maurice c'est ignoble passage à tabac
avant-hier du neveu de Madame Brigitte
Macron c'est aussi un acte qualifiable
et la justice doit être ferme dans un
cas comme dans l'autre mais je vous
demande
mais je vous demande précisément
monsieur le ministre de répondre aux
interrogations de Yannick Morel nous lui
devons s'écarter première question
pourquoi Yannick Morel n'a-t-il pas fait
l'objet d'une protection rapprochée de
l'État depuis le mois de mars deuxième
question pourquoi avoir autorisé la
manifestation anticada du 29 avril un
mois après l'incendie véritable désaveu
du maire qui avait pourtant demandé son
interdiction le 14 mai le 14 avril
après Kalak après Saint-Brevin et avant
d'autres drames allez-vous enfin
interdire ce type de manifestation qui
sont d'évidence d'appels à la haine de
la part de l'extrême droite
[Applaudissements]
pour vos répondre la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur dentaire
d'abord vous me permettrez en saluant
Yannick Morel de me réjouir de l'image
que vient de donner le Sénat puisque
aucun membre n'est resté assis au moment
de l'hommage qui lui a été rendu alors
que nous avons assisté hier
alors que nous avons assisté hier à
l'Assemblée nationale à une scène où une
partie de l'hémicycle ne s'est pas levée
et je pense que sa témoigne précisément
et je pense que ça témoigne précisément
de la volonté qu'il y a
de la
j'aimerais
prétendre défendre la liberté
d'expression en empêchant quelqu'un de
s'exprimer et toujours quelque chose qui
m'a semblé bizarre je commence ce propos
en saluant le fait que tous les élus sur
tous les bancs ici se lèvent alors
qu'hier le rassemblement national a
refusé de se joindre à l'hommage et vous
prétextez que compte tenu de la
formulation de ma phrase ça engendrerait
la moindre gêne
c'est un début de récupération que de
laisser penser qu'il y aurait une façon
qui serait à géométrie variable de
décrire les choses et je veux saluer les
propos de ronanantec qui sont la moindre
hésitation et avec le sens républicain
qu'on lui connaît on a profité aussi
pour rappeler les faits inacceptable
subis par le petit neveu du président de
la République dans un confinement de
violence qui de cette manière-là se
retrouve mesdames et messieurs vous avez
ce matin reçu Yannick maurez dans le
cadre d'une mission plus large portée
par le sédiateur d'Arnaud par l'avenir
de la commune nous allons avoir trois
quatre cinq questions qui seront autant
d'occasions de vous répondre dans les
minutes qui viennent
et je me réjouis que le Sénat au travers
de cette exemple d'un acte de courage
d'intimidation et d'un niveau de
violence qui a été franchi et qui a
atteint des paliers inacceptables essaye
de faire la lumière ce que je souhaite
dans le même temps y compris contenu des
retours que nous avons c'est que vous en
profitiez peut-être pour demander aux
forces de l'ordre à ceux qui travaillent
au sein de Loire-Atlantique qu'elle a
été leur version de leur côté les
retours qu'ils ont eu dans les éléments
qui ne sont donnés il y a eu des
patrouilles de police plusieurs nuits
dans la foulée immédiate du 22 mars je
vous dis ce que je sais il y a eu des
propositions qui ont été faites auprès
d'Yannick Maurice pour faire en sorte
qu'il puisse bénéficier d'un
accompagnement et des tentatives de
prise de contact de la part de la
préfecture ou de la sous-préfecture
j'entends y compris dans la lecture de
ce qui a été l'audition ce matin qui a
manifestement sur l'absence de réunion
publique sur des manifestations qui se
sont tenues des zones d'ombre qui
convient d'éclaircir ce que je pense
c'est qu'une commission aussi importante
que celle là sur un sujet aussi sensible
nécessite sans doute que vous y passiez
encore un peu plus de temps que ce que
vous aviez pu imaginer
[Applaudissements]
quelques secondes monsieur Dantec il
vous reste quelques secondes si vous le
souhaitez oui juste monsieur le ministre
je crois qu'il n'y aurait pas de honte à
reconnaître que sur cette affaire l'État
n'a pas été à l'auteur ça faciliterait
les choses
l'état notre corps
Joël guerriot pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en novembre 2022 le Sénat un
initiative de notre collègue Nathalie
Delattre a voté une loi promulguée en
janvier dernier permettant aux
associations d'élus de se constituer
partie civil pour se tenir les élus ou
leurs proches victimes d'agression ce
texte ouvre aujourd'hui la possibilité à
Yannick Morez mère de Saint-Brévin
d'être défendu par l'Association des
maires de France j'ai invité Yannick
Morez aux tribunes et je suis très
heureux de l'hommage que vous venez de
lui rendre
en avril j'ai animé en sa présence une
réunion avec plus de 50 élus de
loire-atlantiques sur ce sujet tous ont
témoignés d'incivilité et d'agression
dont ils font l'objet ils ressortait un
profond mal-être et de la colère car les
élus portent plainte mais bien souvent
rien ne change trop de plaintes sont
classées sans suite et les auteurs
recommencent de plus belle à titre
d'exemple le maire de Saint-Père-en-Retz
commune voisine de Saint-Brévin est
agressée par le même individu depuis
plus de 3 ans hier Jean-Baptiste
trogneux a été victime d'une agression
odieuse uniquement parce qu'il est le
petit neveu du président de la
République
ces agressions prennent aujourd'hui des
formes multiples certains se cachent
derrière l'anonymat des réseaux sociaux
pour harceler menacer insulter toute
autorité publique et leur famille
d'autres se rendent coupables de
violences physiques
l'ensemble est favorisé par des discours
haineux de certains responsables
politiques on ne peut pas appeler à la
violence et sans laver les mains il faut
que la justice passe avec fermeté il
s'agit avant tout de dissuader en amont
en sanctionnant des coupables par des
mesures plus
coercitives monsieur le ministre comment
assurer à nos élus à leur famille que la
nation et l'État se tiennent à leurs
côtés et que ses actes ne restent pas
impuni
vous répondre la parole est au ministre
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Christophe Béchu monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
je n'aurai aucune difficulté quand nous
irons au terme de l'ensemble de la
lumière qui est nécessaire sur ce qui
s'est fait à Saint-Brévin à partager
avec vous et le constat et la
reconnaissance des dysfonctionnements
s'il y en a eu et je veux dire à Yannick
Morez on le regarde que son exemple a
beaucoup d'écart il nous oblige
parce qu'il suppose de mesurer qui a à
la fois les actes pour lesquels des élus
peuvent parce que ça correspondent leur
décision et d'autres dans lequel il
s'agit d'aller partager une
responsabilité nationale il y a un an
j'étais maire comme beaucoup ici les
intimidations les invectives les
insultes les trucs dans les réseaux
sociaux les commentaires haineux les
affiches les tracts anonymes je connais
beaucoup d'entre nous connaissent
l'année dernière c'est
2265 atteintes à des élus
32% de plus qu'en 2021
en face
compte tenu à la fois du durcissement
des textes
945 sanctions pénales quand on a été
capable de retrouver les auteurs l'enjeu
c'est de franchir de nouveaux paliers
monsieur le sénateur Gueriot d'abord pas
seulement analyser comme le dit le
président kaner mais faire un centre de
coordination de la lutte contre les élus
comment la justice comment la
gendarmerie et la police sont en
capacité les partager des informations
par rapport aux menaces qui visent les
élus et comment on est capable d'y
répondre y compris en systématisant le
suivi de la protection et de
l'accompagnement des élus deuxième chose
nous avons vous avez parlementaire à une
très large majorité considérée que le
port de l'uniforme
devait être une circonstance aggravante
parce que quand on s'en prend un pompier
un gendarme ou un policier derrière
l'uniforme c'est aux valeurs de la
République qu'on s'attaque est-ce que
l'écharpe tricolore n'est pas à bien des
égards une forme d'uniforme républicain
qui mériterait la même reconnaissance
des circonstances aggravantes est-ce que
nous ne pourrions pas là aussi
considérer que ce n'est pas seulement la
personne du maire qui est visée mais ça
fonctionne et à travers elle ceux qui
lui ont été donnés mandat c'est à dire
la République et la démocratie
merci monsieur le ministre dans le cadre
de Yannick Morez c'est la cumulation de
fait avant même qui est une réaction qui
pose problème il aurait fallu très
rapidement réagir c'est avant tout
d'être démocratie qu'il s'agit de
protéger et pour cela et bien il faut
absolument que nos coupables les
coupables des faits et bien et peur de
notre justice merci la parole est à
notre collègue Catherine beniki pour le
groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
la démission de Yannick Morez mère de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins le 9 mai dernier a
suscité indignation générale et un tole
médiatique sans précédent intimidée
depuis des mois abandonné par un
appareil étatique rester sourd à ses
avertissements celui-ci a finalement
rendu son écharpe suite à l'instant du
criminel de son logement familial dans
la nuit du 22 mars dernier ce drame
républicain est malheureusement loin
d'être isolé en effet depuis le décès
tragique du maire de signes en 2019 les
agressions envers les élus de la
République se sont multipliés vous
disiez tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre 2265 plaintes et signalement en
2022 soit une hausse de 32% en un an
pire encore selon le président de la MF
David Linard le seuil fatidique des
millemets démissionnaires depuis les
municipales de 2020 a été franchie nous
en sommes aujourd'hui à 1293 démissions
j'avais déjà eu l'occasion d'alerter le
gouvernement sur la recrudescence des
agressions envers les élus le 13 avril
dernier madame la ministre forme habile
alors annoncé la création prochaine d'un
centre d'analyse et de lutte contre les
atteintes aux élus mais nous savons tous
ce qui se passe sur le terrain un mois
plus tard aucune la réponse pénale
adaptée ne semble à l'ordre du jour et
une certaine impunité règne pour les
auteurs de ces agressions initiative du
Sénat la loi du 24 janvier 2023 permet
aux associations d'élus de se constituer
partie civile pour soutenir au pénal un
élu victime d'agressions cependant les
sanctions ne sont pas à la hauteur
monsieur le ministre combien de
démission supplémentaires faudra-t-il
pour intensifier la répression envers
les auteurs de ces attaques et préserver
ainsi le pacte républicain
bon vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs on aime la
sénatrice belle retti je voudrais tout
d'abord évidemment m'associer à vos mots
pour dire à quel point ces violences
sont inacceptables je veux redire à
Monsieur le Maire tout mon soutien toute
notre solidarité au nom de la première
ministre au nom de Christophe Béchu au
nom de Gérald Darmanin au nom de tout le
gouvernement
dans notre République c'est inacceptable
nous devons briser la spirale de la
violence faite aux élus on ne laissera
rien passer cette violence
et d'autant plus inacceptable que
j'étais mère moi-même jusqu'au 7 juillet
dernier et qu'on sait à quel point les
mers et que vous représentez tous ici en
fait sont les garant de la sécurité sur
leur commune de la protection de
l'environnement de l'action sociale sur
leur commune ils sont dans l'intérêt
général on sait à quel point ils sont
dans le don de soi
cependant je ne peux pas ne pas rappeler
très brièvement à quel point nous sommes
dans l'action vous l'avez dit la
sénatrice de l'être a permis par sa PPL
le fait que les associations d'élus
puissent se porter partie civiles oui
c'est un élément oui la loi qui a été
portée en 2019 par notre collègue
Sébastien Lecornu engagement et
proximité vise à renforcer comme l'a dit
madame la Première ministre la
protection des élus oui des circulaires
pas moins de 3 qui ont été envoyés au
parquet demandant une réponse pénale
ferme et rapide cependant est-ce que
pour autant nous en restons là est-ce
que pour autant nous voulons amplifier
ce qui est fait ce que nous voulons
aller plus loin la réponse est oui et là
je m'adresse à vous monsieur sénateur
qui n'avait cité que ce centre de lutte
que ce centre d'analyse que j'ai cité
effectivement dans un de mes propos mais
ce n'est pas que cela nous sommes aussi
là pour d'abord et avant tout protéger
les élus donc nous allons amplifier ce
que nous faisons et j'aurai le plaisir
de l'annoncer ce soir après avoir
rencontré Monsieur le Maire de
Saint-Brévin au côté de Madame la
première ministre parce que l'action
vous l'avez tous suivi au corps nous
aussi au gouvernement nous l'avons
chevillé au corps l'action et donc ce
soir je dévoile risque que nous allons
faire à court terme là maintenant pour
protéger nos élus mais aussi je vous
expliquerai pourquoi comprendre est
important pourquoi ce centre est
important pourquoi le choc civique est
important et nous apporterons aussi
madame la sénatrice une réponse
judiciaire je vous remercie
madame la ministre ce qui arrive à
Monsieur Morel n'est pas isolé hein je
crois que tout ce qui arrive renvoie à
l'incapacité chronique de réaffirmer
l'autorité de l'État l'urgence est là
sans mesurer répressives appropriée le
mandat municipal est menacé et sans les
maires c'est la République elle-même qui
menace ruine merci
la parole est à notre collègue Françoise
Gatel pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président les
difficultés les démissions s'enchaînent
et ces graines comme les questions
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ne savait pas
que ce serait ardu très difficile voire
risquer beaucoup de citoyens ce sont
engagés juste pour servir homme et femme
de devoirs plutôt que de pouvoir les
mères sont trop souvent contraints
empêcher démunies submergées de normes
et d'injonctions mais il reste
responsable de tout les voici
aujourd'hui avec leur famille confrontés
aux délitement et à la violence de la
société qui les prend pour cible de la
mort du maire de signe en 2019 à la
démission 6 symbolique de Monsieur le
Maire de Saint-Brévin que je salue avec
beaucoup de respect des missions et
difficultés s'enchaînent certes des
dispositions ont été votées mises en
œuvre il faut l'admettre car nous
connaissons les remèdes
éduquer protéger sanctionné et surtout
prévenir et empêcher ceci suppose que le
couple mère préfet que nous avons tant
célébré pendant la crise du covid soit
fort et puissant partout dans tous les
territoires et auprès de tous les élus à
force Yori quand les tâches amères
d'exécuter une mission en son nom madame
la ministre monsieur le ministre je sais
pas qui me répondra écoute émotion nous
le faisons tout je sais que ça n'est pas
simplement votre attitude mais cela ne
suffit pas quand ta mère doit détourner
le regard devant ses agresseurs il nous
l'a dit ce matin quand ta mère est
condamnée à quitté la commune pour
laquelle il s'est engagé et a changé de
vie l'heure est vraiment la
détermination et à l'action la démission
du maire de Saint-Brevin la démission
des maires nous oblige madame la
ministre quels sont les intentions du
gouvernement avant que vous les
précisiez à la télévision on serait
ravis de les avoir ici au Parlement
ministre délégués dans charge des
collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
et donc pour redire et le redire à
Monsieur le Maire il y a tous les maires
qui font l'objet de violence faite aux
élus ces dernières semaines mais j'ai
envie de vous dire tout à fait en
introduction que le diagnostic nous le
partageons que c'est par l'écoute c'est
par la proximité c'est par le respect
les uns des autres c'est par la
solidarité mais aussi c'est par l'action
je vous le redis monsieur le sénateur
que l'on va pouvoir endiguer cette
violence faite aux élus alors vous
parlez de la du couple pressé mère on le
connaît tous ici il est efficace il est
à l'action alors bien sûr nous allons
écouter Monsieur le Maire et nous allons
écouter je l'écouterai aux côtés de
madame la Première ministre les raisons
qui lui font percevoir que effectivement
les services de l'État n'ont pas été à
la hauteur de vos attentes et on va vous
écouter et ça dans l'esprit de ce qu'a
dit Christophe Béchu tout à l'heure de
toujours s'améliorer oui on va
s'améliorer de ce que vous allez nous
dire Monsieur le Maire et de votre
perception de cette inaction perçue par
vous moi je veux pas rappeler ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure on a le
sentiment d'avoir agi cependant on est
vraiment à l'écoute et avec une envie
cheville au corps d'avancer alors vous
me demandez de dévoiler quelques actions
seulement il s'agit ici de vous le dire
en deux minutes donc c'est un peu court
me semble-t-il mais je voudrais juste
citer un point un point
ça s'appelle l'alarme élu c'est 3000
référents dans la gendarmerie et dans la
police nationale qui seront dès le début
de la semaine prochaine investis de une
extrême proximité ce sera des référents
violents aux élus ça a été décidé par le
début de la semaine par Gérald Darmanin
et c'est ce qui va faire juste si vous
voulez bien m'écouter une seconde c'est
super important j'ai plus que 10
secondes à l'armée lui ça veut dire
qu'il faut que vous invitiez les maires
à donner leur numéro de téléphone au
préfet au gendarmes ou à la police pour
que quand ils appel
leront écoutez-moi pour que pour
que puisse bénéficier d'un traitement
spécifique messieurs et mesdames les
sénateurs je vous en dirai plus un peu
plus tard merci à vous
la parole est à notre collègue Cécile
cucarman pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique vous
avez la parole
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les élus leur famille sont de plus en
plus confrontés à des actes de violence
d'agression d'intimidation parce qu'ils
agissent pour l'intérêt de leur
population de leur collectivité et de
leur territoire je veux au nom de mon
groupe leur apporter tout mon soutien et
redire qu'aucune violence n'est
acceptable la violence n'est pas dans
l'ADN de notre sensibilité politique
nous serons toujours dans le camp de
ceux qui la condamnent la démission de
notre collègue mère de
Saint-Brévin-les-Pins n'est pas
dans un ciel serein elle fait suite
au besoin répété de l'extrême droite
depuis plusieurs semaines elle s'ajoute
au plus de 4000 démissions des lieux
municipaux depuis 2020 dont plus de 1200
maires la non-action ainsi que la
banalisation de cette violence
permettent aux auteurs d'agir sans
limite cela met en danger les élus leur
famille mais aussi notre démocratie
notre République nous devons donc
redonner du sens à l'engagement le
sacraliser nous avons tous notre rôle à
jouer en responsabilité les communes
qu'elles soient rurales urbaines ou
d'outre-mer demeure le premier lieu de
vie et de solidarité cellules de base de
la République elles doivent retrouver
toutes leurs places dans l'organisation
démocratique de notre pays cette une
urgence démocratique c'est une urgence
pour la République Monsieur le Ministre
comment entendez-vous redonner du sens à
l'engagement
de ces milliers d'élus locaux qui au
quotidien agissent pour l'intérêt
général et l'intérêt de chacune et de
chacun comment entendez-vous éviter de
telles dysfonctionnement à l'avenir
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Herman
d'abord
vous l'avez dit au-delà de Saint-Brévin
c'est plus largement le sens de
l'engagement municipal le sens de
l'engagement de mère que nous devons
évoquer et mal nommer les choses c'est
ajouter au malheur du monde
la démission du maire de Saint-Brévin a
été poussé par des manifestants
d'extrême droite et provoquées par un
acte scandaleux visant sa famille et son
intégrité physique mais les 1293 des
missions depuis trois ans elles n'ont
pas toutes la même cause certaines sont
liées à des violences de tous origines
parfois sans arrière-pensée politique
liés à la bêtise à des conflits
voisinage et dans d'autres cas à des
affaires internes aux équipes à des
difficultés par rapport au poids des
normes à la multiplicité des réunions à
des difficultés dans une
intercommunalité entre mère en nombre de
démission amis mandat nous en sommes au
même nombre en ce qui concerne les mers
1400 sur les trois premières années du
mandat 2014-2020
1293 quand on s'arrête au mois de mars
sur les trois premières années avec la
parenthèse covid qui bouleverse sans
doute une partie de l'analyse puisque
certains mandats ont commencé avec du
retard je me réjouis de l'initiative
transpartizane de l'avenir de la commune
et je serai heureux d'être auditionné
comme c'est prévu pour vous préciser ce
à quoi nous pensons le sujet du statut
de l'élu
la question du nombre de réunions et
même je vais vous dire puisque c'est un
sujet sur lequel vous travaillez
le statut du secrétaire de mairie du
collaborateur qui permet de soulager de
manière concrète le maire voilà une
oeuvre utile pour faire en sorte
d'avancer et de regarder comment on peut
de manière intelligente faire en sorte
de limiter une part de la charge mentale
qui accompagne la fonction municipale et
puis collectivement tel que vous venez
de le faire refusez toutes les violences
refuser toutes les excuses à ceux qui
décident d'utiliser autre chose que la
démocratie pour remettre en cause des
démissions c'est le bon moyen parce que
ça commence avec le coup d'école qui se
justifie avec le courrier anonyme parce
que le terrain est pas constructible et
ça se poursuit après par un changement
de nature dans les actes et c'est au
premier signe que nous conférons par
collectivement pour protéger les élus je
sais à quel point le Sénat dans sa plus
la réalité est aux côtés des élus et se
tient précisément pour faire en sorte de
les préserver madame cut Carmen vous
avez quelques secondes non
la parole est à notre collègue Dominique
Théophile pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue
madame la ministre et chère collègues je
salue bien sûr la présence du maire
Yannick Morez et m'associe avec le
groupe RDPI à l'hommage qui vient d'être
rendu nous devons condamner toutes les
formes de violence madame la ministre
dimanche en Guadeloupe une mère de
famille est morte au volant de sa
voiture elle a reçu une balle dans la
tête
mercredi ce sont deux jeune homme de 18
et 22 ans qui ont trouvé la mort au
Lamentin et aux Abymes en Guadeloupe eux
aussi par armes à feu ces drames ce sont
les derniers en date d'une liste qui ne
cesse de s'allonger depuis le début de
l'année une quarantaine de personnes ont
ainsi été blessées ou tués par balle
dans notre archipel sans qu'il ne soit
permis d'espérer un retour au calme
cette violence nous ne la découvrons pas
depuis quelques années elle explose en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique elle
s'accompagne d'un phénomène de et se
nourrit du trafic d'armes à feu qui
déséquilibre la Caraïbe et qui
ensanglant Tahiti le pouvoir public ont
pris la mesure de ce phénomène et il me
faut saluer le travail exceptionnel des
forces de l'ordre et des fonctionnaires
de justice il y a quelques mois c'est
une vaste opération menée sous l'égide
d'interpols qui a ainsi permis la saisie
d'armes et de munitions cette réponse
pourtant n'est pas suffisante elle le
sera quand cesseront les drames qui en
deuil chaque semaine des familles madame
la ministre quelle réponse
supplémentaire entendez-vous apporter
pour enrayer ce cycle de violence
comment mieux lutter contre un trafic
d'armes qui dépasse de loin nos
frontières les collectivités locales la
société civile et les familles sont
engagées dans ce combat au quotidien
elles attendent de l'État une réponse
forte et déterminée nous ne pourrons pas
tenir
les armes circulent comme un achat dans
un commerce
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre
délégué en charge des collectivités
territoriales merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Théophile
vous avez raison la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique connaissent depuis quelques
années une hausse des violences avec
armes et les homicides l'utilisa Sion
d'armes à feu est en constante
augmentation étant à se banaliser avec
une utilisation régulière par des primo
délinquants dans le but de se protéger
en Guadeloupe 230 armes ont ainsi été
saisies dans ce cadre en 2022 ce qui
démontre la banalisation du transport et
du port d'armes sur le territoire alors
des actions de prévention d'abord
campagne de communication et diffusion
de messages télévisuels sur les chaînes
locales et sur les réseaux sociaux
financés par le fond le FIPD mais vous
le savez réunion régulière de
concertation avec la société civile afin
de développer de plus en plus de bonnes
pratiques mais aussi la multiplication
des opérations de contrôle menées à
l'appui d'arrêter préfectoraux
spécifiques interdisant la vente la
détention et le transport d'armes de
catégorie C3 et d sur le territoire de
ces deux départements ensuite le
développement le développement des
moyens d'enquête judiciaires notamment
d'enquêteurs spécialisés
spécialisé cyber chargé d'enquêter sur
la vente et l'achat d'armes par Internet
en 2022 un enquêteur nouvelle
technologie de la gendarmerie ainsi
contribué à l'identification de
plusieurs trafics et au démantèlement de
natelier de transformation de pistolet
d'alarme en armes létale située sur la
commune du Robert
la coopération avec les États voisins
relance des échanges avec Sainte-Lucie
dans le cadre de la commission mixte
renforcement de la coopération avec la
marée chaussée de Saint-Martin tout ça
vous le savez mais il faut poursuivre
renforcer soyez convaincus monsieur le
sénateur de l'engagement total du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour et de
l'outre-mer pour continuer la lutte
contre les trafics à Marseille pas
seulement en Guadeloupe et à la
Martinique merci
la parole est à notre collègue Arnaud
Bazin pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
président madame la Première ministre
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie et
des finances on l'avait bien compris
elle était 2021 c'était juré le quoi
qu'il en coûte c'est fini pour la loi de
finance 2023 le mantra avait un peu
changé c'était chaque euro compte et en
même temps depuis quelques semaines le
président de la République et le
gouvernement rivalise d'annonce de
dépenses nouvelles supplémentaires par
centaines de millions voir par milliards
d'euros 2 milliards d'euros pour le plan
vélo 2 milliards d'euros de baisse pour
l'impôt des classes moyennes 1 milliard
d'euros pour les lycées professionnels
cela peut représenter 18 milliards
d'euros en cumulé d'ici la fin du
quinquennat dans le même temps les
intérêts de la dette cette année vont
augmenter de 12 milliards d'euros
bientôt le service de la dette sera le
premier budget de l'État et l'impôt sur
le revenu des Français effet ni suffira
même plus dans le même temps les
prévisions économiques du gouvernement
nous les avions jugés optimistes en
examinant la loi de finances 1% de
croissance ce n'est pas ce que nous
observerons le P le FMI avait dit 06 %,
c'est sensiblement ce qui se confirme
dans les premiers chiffres que nous
avons alors dans ce contexte
incertain pour ne pas dire inquiétant
des finances publiques quand cette
baisse d'impôts en faveur des classes
moyennes pourra-t-elle avoir lieu
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge des comptes
publics monsieur Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bazin vous abordez des sujets
que nous avons longuement évoqué ici
même lors du débat d'orientation des
finances publiques il y a quelques jours
au cours d'une soirée avec le rapporteur
général Husson le président rénal est
beaucoup d'entre vous d'abord l'annonce
du président de la République sur la
baisse d'impôts pour les classes
moyennes je veux rappeler qu'elle
s'inscrit dans une politique résolue de
renforcement du pouvoir d'achat des
Français qui travaillent qui nous a
amenés à la suppression compensée de la
taxe d'habitation à la redevance télé
qui a été supprimée à la baisse de
l'impôt sur le revenu pour les deux
premières tranches à la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires et à
l'indexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu sur l'inflation cette politique
elle a un sens c'est redonné de
l'oxygène à tous ces Français qui se
lèvent le matin qui travaillent et qui
ont parfois le sentiment qu'il finance
avec leurs impôts un modèle qui permet à
certains de ne pas travailler ou des
services publics qui se dégradent ce qui
nécessite pour nous évidemment de leur
redonner du pouvoir d'achat et d'agir
douter d'une croissance à 2,5% en 2022
nous l'avons dépassé et qu'à l'automne
dernier certains remettaient en cause le
fait que nous aurions une croissance
positive en 2023 et que les
prévisionnistes sont en train
progressivement de s'aligner sur notre
prévision à 1% de croissance pour cette
année 2023 le FMI que vous avez évoqué
est à 0,8 l'eau CDE est à 0,7 et donc
oui nous avons une économie qui résiste
parce que nous avons des entreprises qui
embauchent et qui investissent c'est bon
pour le pays c'est bon pour l'emploi et
c'est même bon pour les finances
publiques je vous remercie
monsieur Bazin merci monsieur le
Président
Monsieur le Ministre le président de la
République lui-même a précisé que cette
baisse d'impôt sur les classes moyennes
serait effective quand la trajectoire
des finances publiques le permettra à
travers les documents budgétaires que
vous avez rappelé par être raisonnable
disons moins des raisonnable d'envisager
cette baisse à l'échéance du présent du
précédent quinquennat en conséquence les
Français auront bien compris que la
situation des classes moyennes
s'améliorera quand Emmanuel Macron ne
sera plus président de la République
la parole est à notre collègue Maria
Arlette Carlotti pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et République
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président à Marseille
la pègre tu elle tue sur fond de
vendetta entre banc de rivales régnant
sur les trafics de stupéfiants depuis le
début de l'année Marseille vit au rythme
donne assassinat par semaine et les
réseaux ont plus que jamais la même mise
sur le quotidien des habitants car les
gangs ne se tuent plus entre eux ils ont
font de plus en plus de victimes
collatérales des enfants de 15 ans
assassinés une femme tue au volant de sa
voiture lors d'un échange de tirs un
homme atteint d'une balle perdu alors
qui jouait au bas aux cartes au bar du
coin un jeune tué aux jambes tout touché
aux jambes par une rafale tirée à
travers le sa porte d'entrée comme ça
fusillade à l'aveugle séquestration l'un
de change mortel diffusé sur les réseaux
sociaux les trafiquants imposent leur
terreur avec mon collègue Jérôme Durin
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
victimes de leur famille de la
population qui se sent impuissante
vulnérables abandonné impuissante parce
que assinia résidence parce qu'elles
n'ont plus les moyens de quitter leur
cité HLM des quartiers qui sont mal
irrigués en transport en commun des
déserts médicaux et l'école insalubre
que le maire de Marseille a la volonté
de réhabiliter déjà déjà ils avaient le
sentiment que la République les avait
abandonnés mais désormais ils savent que
chaque jour il risque leur vie car il ne
faut pas se trouver au mauvais endroit
au mauvais moment la police pylone les
points de Deal fait des records de prise
de chiffres c'est bien mais à l'évidence
ça ne marche pas vous avez déployé des
moyens importants notamment sur
Marseille ça ne suffit pas c'est donc
sur votre doctrine que je vous interroge
est-ce que vous croyez par exemple que
c'était vraiment le moment d'affaiblir
la police judiciaire alors que leur
objectif c'est justement de démanteler
les réseaux oui la guerre des gangs nous
l'avons entendu sur ce répartit partout
dans le pays et nous aurions temps de
penser que cette situation n'est propre
qu'à Marseille nous ici nous soutenons
les forces de l'ordre nous respectons la
police mais quand les choses ne
fonctionnent pas c'est au ministre à
revoir sa copie alors aujourd'hui madame
la ministre au-delà de Marseille c'est
pour toutes les villes de France que
nous nous indignions et que nous vous
demandons ce que vous comptez faire
pour vous répondre la parole ministre en
charge des collectivités territoriales
merci Monsieur le le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Carlotti oui nous partageons
ce constat inacceptable en fait depuis
le début de l'année ce sont 17 personnes
qui ont été tuées dans le cadre domicile
lié au trafic de stupéfiants et je
voudrais ici au nom de Gérald Darmanin
de madame la Première ministre et de
tout le gouvernement avoir un mot pour
leur famille et leurs proches endeuillé
mais face à cette situation intolérable
là où nous divergeons c'est que le
ministère de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
est pleinement mobilisée d'ores et déjà
c'est pas ce que nous quand on fait
c'est ce que nous faisons et si vous me
le permettez je vais le rappeler entre
2021 2022 c'est 300 policiers qui ont
été dépêchés en renfort et contrairement
à ce que vous disiez en début d'année
c'est dix nouveaux policiers qui sont
venus renforcer la police judiciaire et
qui permettent de créer un groupe
supplémentaire pour l'office anti
stupéfiant ces trois compagnies de CRS
qui ont également été affectés en
permanence à Marseille soit un total de
plus 240 policiers ces 30 jeunes
policiers en sortie d'école qui ont été
infectés à Marseille depuis le 2 mai
madame la sénatrice 11 nouveaux
policiers arriveront à la police
judiciaire d'ici septembre pour
renforcer la brigade de recherche et
d'intervention 90 postes qui ont été
ouverts rien que sur Marseille dans le
cas du prochain mouvement de mutation et
qui arriveront en septembre prochain
enfin grâce à la loop me que vous avez
votée en ce début d'année une nouvelle
compagnie de type CRS numéro 8 sera
implanté à Marseille et même d'ici la
fin de l'année 2023 cette politique
montre des effets concrets d'ores et
déjà madame la sénatrice bien sûr
insuffisant mais il me faut les rappeler
de janvier à mars 2023 ce sont 362
opérations visant des points de deal qui
ont été effectués à Marseille
aboutissant la saisie de 500 kg de
drogue 40 armes 800
000 incroyable d'avoir criminel des
armes 800 000 armes d'avoir criminel
donc oui madame il nous faut poursuivre
et vous avez raison de nous interroger
mais entendez les réponses que nous
apportons d'ores et déjà je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue max
brichon pour le groupe les républicains
le président monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale après un long
silence votre enseigne était
particulièrement attendu on vous annonce
loin de répondre aux besoins de réforme
de l'école
futur plus polémique que saluer elles
ont cependant offert de nouveaux débats
sur la laïcité et la mixité sociale j'ai
donc trois questions à vous poser à
l'aune de la composition du nouveau
Conseil des Sages de laïcité
entendez-vous redéfinir ce principe
fondamental d'autres République qui
prévoient jusqu'à présent à l'école
publique alors que le chef de l'État
vous invite à ne pas réveiller de vieux
conflits pourrez-vous présenter un jour
votre plan sur la mixité sociale à
l'école finalement monsieur le ministre
avez-vous la confiance du président de
la République pour réformer et diriger
l'éducation nationale
pour vous répondre la parole est tôt
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse monsieur papendaï
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
Brisson 3 questions plutôt ou plutôt
deux auquel je vais répondre
successivement la première porte sur les
questions de laïcité j'ai eu l'occasion
déjà de m'exprimer devant vous pour
indiquer que d'une part la laïcité doit
être observée de manière ferme et
stricte nous devons respecter
strictement la loi de 2004 qui est notre
boussole en la matière être ferme à
l'égard de celles et ceux qui
contreviennent au principe de laïcité et
depuis l'automne il y a eu des conseils
de discipline il y a eu des sanctions
qui ont été prononcées mais j'ai
également eu l'occasion de dire que la
laïcité c'est aussi une pédagogie la
laïcité ne doit pas seulement être
contrainte elle doit être aimée c'est ce
que disait les républicains à la fin du
19e siècle la République ne doit pas
être crainte seulement elle doit être
aimée nous devons donc développer une
pédagogie de la laïcité c'est très
important pour convaincre et ne pas
simplement faire respecter au sens
strict du terme nous avons pour cela un
conseil des sages qui oriente l'action
du ministre fournit des éléments
intellectuels des éléments de doctrine
et nous avons aussi en parallèle une
administration avec plus de 600
personnes dans les équipes valeurs de la
République qui travaillent à faire
respecter la laïcité sur le terrain de
façon ferme avec discernement mais de
manière très ferme en ce qui concerne
votre deuxième question je vais dévoiler
ce soir puisque nous allons signer un
accord avec le secrétariat général de
l'enseignement catholique pour ce qui
concerne le privé et une batterie de
mesure en ce qui concerne le public de
de nature à favoriser la mixité car la
mixité c'est bon pour le climat scolaire
c'est bon pour le climat social c'est
bon pour le niveau des élèves c'est bon
aussi pour la laïcité monsieur Brisson
monsieur le ministre acteur le président
de République face caméra
multiplie depuis un an les annonces sur
l'organisation scolaire et son évolution
acte 2 seuls et en militant pour enfin
exister vous concentrez sur deux sujets
une laïcité à géométrie variable qui
conduit au torpillage du conseil des
sages et qui laisse sans directive
proviseur et professeur puis en simulage
éculé de l'enseignement privé qui serait
vieux fantasme de gauche la source des
défaillances de l'enseignement public
acte 3 le président République vous
rappelle à l'ordre et vos plans sont
rangés au placard le problème est qu'à
force de tirer a eu et Adia la rue de
Grenelle et l'Élysée passe à côté de
l'essentiel la réforme d'un service
public à bout de souffle cessez donc de
jouer avec l'Élysée ée ce bien mauvais
votre ville monsieur le ministre
a de visiter personnelles et clivantes
la France a besoin de donner l'or
réformateur pour son école merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est notre collègue Elisabeth
Doisneau pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question concerne les mineurs non
accompagnés une question qui n'est pas
nouvelle et qui demande une réponse en
fait interministérielle parce qu'elle
peut aussi bien avoir une réponse sur le
plan du ministère de l'Intérieur pour
les flux migratoires que sur la justice
avec l'évaluation de la minorité que sur
la solidarité que sur la protection de
l'enfance que sur l'éducation même le
travail quand nous avons des chefs
d'entreprise qui demande à ce que on
puisse maintenir déjà sur notre
territoire pour assurer soit des
apprentissages ou du travail dans nos
entreprises artisanales donc c'est
vraiment un ensemble de réponses qui est
attendu et aujourd'hui le cri d'alarme
est lancé par le président de
l'Association des départements de France
François Sauvadet qui dit que la
situation est alarmante et il a raison
la situation est alarmante 5000 mineurs
non accompagné qui sont arrivés depuis
le début de l'année et notamment 2000
dans les Alpes-Maritimes et je voudrais
rappeler le chiffre entre 2021 et 2022
c'était 900 mineurs non accompagnés en
plus dans le seul département des
Alpes-Maritimes et la situation est
vraiment catastrophique nous devons agir
et je voudrais vous poser tout
simplement cette question va-t-on parler
dans la loi immigration de cette
question des mineurs non accompagné il
n'y a rien à ce jour dans cette loi
concernant les jeunes alors que nous
devons et les accompagner avec humanité
mais aussi avec responsabilité et faire
en sorte que les choses soient
acceptables aussi pour l'ensemble de la
population nous devons aussi
penser à ce que nous avons voté dans la
loi taquet c'est à dire du 7 février
2022 nous avions trois articles qui
étaient concernés par les mineurs non
accompagnés aujourd'hui rien n'est
possible puisque ce ne ce n'est pas
passé au Conseil d'État la troisième
question c'est comment comptez-vous
faire pour aider financièrement les
conseils départementaux qui sont à bout
de souffle aujourd'hui et les moyens
financiers ont diminué ces dernières
années je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole que la
ministre délégué
en charge des collectivités
territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Doisneau avec le ministre de
l'intérieur des outre-merges Gérard
Darmanin nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés sur cette question et vous le
savez des mineurs étrangers non
accompagnés qui est à la fois complexe
mais crucial pour nos territoires et nos
départements
et pour eux bien sûr madame
c'est une question particulièrement
actuelle puisqu'en 2022 quelques
chiffres ils étaient 14 782 en 2021 ils
sont 11 315 il était 11315 et les
remontées des départements qui ont la
charge comme vous l'avez indiqué de
l'accueil de ces jeunes montre une
augmentation prévisible de ces chiffres
cette préoccupation nous la partageons
c'est pour cela que la mission nationale
des mineurs non accompagnés de la
Direction de la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse au ministère de la jeunesse
et pleinement mobilisé et à l'écoute des
remontées des départements c'est encore
pour cela que je suis personnellement en
contact régulier avec le président des
départements de France cher François
Sauvadet c'est pour cela évidemment qui
a été organisé à Vendôme la semaine
dernière une rencontre avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur la secrétaire d'État
l'enfance et qu'ils ont reçu ensemble
les élus les représentants du
département des Alpes-Maritimes tout
particulièrement exposé dans ce contexte
nous allons ainsi apporter des réponses
concrètes à la situation de tension que
vous avez décritée que nous partageons
et que connaît ce département en
particulier mais comme vous l'avez dit
que connaissent aussi d'autres
départements soutien aux équipes
départementales en charge de
l'évaluation recherche de la mise en
oeuvre des solidarités inter
départementale suspension de la clé de
répartition concours exceptionnel de
l'État toutes ces pistes sont à l'étude
actuellement pour améliorer encore notre
dispositif en lien avec les
collectivités tout particulièrement avec
l'Association des départements de France
le soutien de l'État au département dans
cette mission très sensible et totale
offrir un séminaire la prise en charge
nécessaire est indispensable comme vous
l'avez indiqué comme nous devons
préserver tout comme nous devons
préserver les équilibres de notre
République et des territoires également
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
philippe Dominati pour les
présidents madame la ministre il y a
quelques jours un quotidien à publier
son enquête annuelle concernant
l'inquiétude des Français vis-à-vis de
leur liberté individuelle
64% d'entre eux considèrent que les
atteintes à la liberté individuelle se
sont aggravés au cours de la dernière
décennie
ce chiffre est également réparti entre
les électeurs de gauche plus de 70%, les
entreprises 78% et évidemment les autres
catégories de France
les interdictions peuvent elles sont
quotidiennes les collectivités
territoriales y participent
je n'ai pas le temps évidemment les
énumérer mais ça va de la possibilité de
se laver d'arroser de chasser de choisir
son médecin sa santé se faire vacciner
ou pas se faire vacciner de choisir sa
fin de vie
pour autant les Français sont les
citoyens les plus prodigues vis-à-vis de
du pays il paye la dette il paye les
impôts les plus élevés des démocraties
ils payent le plus grand nombre d'agents
publics et l'État mord la main de ceux
qui les nourrissent je suis un
républicain
je ne suis pas fan des monarchies parce
que je suis toujours étonné de voir que
des contribuables peuvent payer ou
enrichir le patrimoine de leur prince
mais force est de constater que entre le
millier d'anglais qui est au sacre de
Charles III
et la pauvreté la solitude de notre
président de la République sur les
Champs-Élysées entouré de dix policiers
pour un spectateur je m'interroge ma
question est de savoir
madame la Première ministre madame les
ministres quelles instructions vous
donner à votre administration pour avoir
les précautions de ne plus enquiquiner
les Français au nom des précautions
élémentaires au nom de la trilogie
pour vous répondre
la parole est à la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs vous interrogez
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer Gérald Darmanin sur un récent
monsieur le sénateur Dominati sur un
récent sondage de l'Ifop
personne bien entendu ne concerne de
conteste le sérieux de l'institut Ifop
mais nous ne perdons pas de vue qu'on
parle ici d'une perception
subjective d'un sentiment si on s'en
tient la réalité des faits et du droit
nous souhaitons insister sur le fait que
nous sommes dans un état de droit et que
l'action du gouvernement
tout comme celui des forces de l'ordre
et guidé par nos principes
constitutionnels et nos règles
juridiques que nous partageons tous la
liberté d'expression et en son sein la
liberté de manifestation sont des
principes constitutionnels auxquels nous
sommes tous attachés mais nous rappelons
également que des restrictions libertins
individuelles sont possibles dans notre
État de droit sous conditions bien
évidemment ainsi les restrictions à la
liberté de manifester doivent être
strictement proportionnées au motif
d'intérêt général à défendre
les restrictions à liberté de manifester
doivent aussi être motivés par un risque
avéré de troubles à l'ordre public alors
vous le savez peut-être monsieur mais ça
me semblait opportun de le rappeler je
rappelle également que dans notre pays
toute restriction liberté individuelle
est soumise au strict contrôle d'un juge
des arrêtés préfectoraux d'interdiction
de manifestations ont déjà été confirmés
par le juge mais faut-il rappeler que
d'autres arrêtés préfectoraux
d'interdictions de manifestations ont
aussi été annulés par la justice alors
quelques exemples un colloque de
l'Action française autorisé par le
tribunal administratif samedi 13 mai
alors que le préfet de police avait pris
un arrêté d'interdiction une
manifestation organisée par la même
action française dimanche 14 mai qui a
défilé en hommage à Jeanne d'Arc la
démonstration est ainsi faite que nos
institutions fonctionnent et que l'État
de droit est respecté je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Laurence Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président
un petit
moment fort qu'il a bien mérité alors en
40 ans un quart des oiseaux c'est à dire
800 millions d'oiseaux ont disparu en
Europe
non non
ne vous laissez pas aller c'est
plaisanterie facile
et c'est effondrement est directement
imputable aux pesticides et à
l'agriculture intensive chaque année
300.000 personnes dont 12 000 enfants
meurent prématurément de la pollution de
l'air en Europe le niveau des nappes
phréatiques et dramatique et l'Europe du
Sud brûle déjà alors que nous sommes
loin de l'été encore
et voilà que le Président de la
République
la France risque avec cette déclaration
si c'était si elle était confirmée de
torpiller les efforts que l'Europe doit
faire pour accélérer sa transition
écologique alors nous sommes dans une
course de vitesse aujourd'hui contre la
destruction du vivant nous sommes dans
des difficiles négociations dans l'Union
européenne dans quel camp est la France
qui faut-il croire est-ce qu'il faut
croire le ministrechu qui au 1er janvier
nous souhaitait à tous une année
d'accélération de la transition
écologique ou est-ce qu'il faut croire
le ministre Lescure qui demande 50 poses
de la transition écologique
pour vous répondre la parole l'État au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs de la sénatrice
rossignol
d'abord merci d'avoir fait écho
cette étude hier qui pointe cette
disparition inquiétante de la mortalité
des
oiseaux à l'échelle européenne et les
causes qui sont avérées nous sommes à
quelques jours
d'une séquence très importante à
l'Unesco de la négociation d'un traité
sur la fin de la pollution plastique qui
va se tenir en France parce que le
Président de la République a souhaité je
suis heureux que vous m'interrogiez sur
ces propos qui ne doivent pas être mal
compris
d'abord dans quel cas ça se passe dans
le cadre d'une conférence de presse
choisie par le Président de la
République à l'Élysée pour expliquer
qu'il faut accélérer sur la
réindustrialisation écologique du pays
et ça commence par une diapo projetée
qui est celle du GIEC pour expliquer ce
qui se passe et pour dire que nous
devons changer de braquet parce que
pendant trop d'années on a baissé nos
émissions en désutera industrialisant et
que l'écologie ceux qui en parle le plus
sont pas nécessairement ceux qui ont
fait le plus sous le quinquennat que
vous avez ardemment soutenu la baisse
des émissions était de 1% par an elle a
été doublée pendant le dernier
quinquennat et l'ambition de la doubler
à nouveau ce qui a été annoncé ce
jour-là c'est que nous allons nous
saisir d'un texte européen négocié par
le Président de la République le net 0
pour faire en sorte de pouvoir attribuer
des subventions au projet qui
correspondent à une excellence
écologique environnementale dans un
cadre qui est celui de la planification
écologique souhaitée par le Haut Conseil
pour le climat confié à la première
ministre de manière à assurer la
transversalité
le sujet c'est vu le nombre de textes
qui viennent d'être voté et ceux qui
sont encore devant nous riches et sur
dans quelle mesure nous faisons en sorte
maintenant de mettre les financements
c'est la phrase du président de la
République pour appliquer les
dispositions qui ont été prises plutôt
que d'ajouter des textes à des textes
alors que nous en avons déjà beaucoup
devant nous un exemple euro 7 on a il y
a quelques mois dit ensemble qu'il
fallait qu'on aille vers la
planification de la transition
écologique des voitures avec
l'électrification dans le même temps
l'évolution de la norme ne doit pas
concerner le moteur c'est la pause mais
se concentrer sur les autres éléments il
n'y a pas de contradiction entre le fait
d'expliquer qu'on doit intensifier notre
action sur la base des textes existants
qui sont déjà nombreux tout en
continuant en négocier de nouveau mais
en ajoutant pas chaque jour un texte qui
vient remplacer le précédent l'ambition
est totale la pose n'est pas pour
l'ambition
la parole de notre collègue Françoise
Dumont pour le groupe les républicain
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adressait à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la ministre en juin 2022 la
Commission européenne a publié une
proposition de règlement intitulée loi
sur la restauration de la nature il
s'agit de l'une des mises en application
de la stratégie européenne du pacte vert
dans ce contexte la commission
Environnement du Parlement européen qui
examine au fond le projet de règlement
doit entériner sa position le 15 juin
prochain dans son article 10 la loi
prévoit que les États membres de romps
devront écouter bien augmenter la
quantité de bois mort debout et au sol
la connectivité forestière les stocks de
carbone organiques dans les sols ainsi
que la part de forêt d'âge différents
avec une hausse de tous ces éléments qui
devrait être mesurées tous les trois ans
dans l'ensemble des États membres à
compter de 2030 cet article devient donc
complètement à la doctrine française de
lutte contre les incendies de forêts que
nous avons ici au Sénat renforcés et
sécurisé avec l'adoption de la
proposition de loi de nos collègues
jean-baci Anne-Catherine Loisier Pascal
Martin et Olivier riadman visant à
renforcer l'approvision la prévention
pardon et la lutte contre
l'intensification et l'extension du
risque incendie et qui prévoit entre
autres de gérer d'améliorer
l'aménagement et la valorisation des
forêts en appréhendant la défense contre
les incendies à l'échelle du massif de
financer la reconstitution de forêt plus
résiliente après l'incendie aussi madame
la ministre concernant ce texte européen
de restauration de la nature quelles
sont les actions françaises entreprises
pour faire reconnaître l'expertise et le
particularisme français en matière de
lutte contre les feux de forêt merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre des liens en charge des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
Dumont en fait le 4 avril le Sénat
adopté et vous l'avez dit à l'unanimité
j'étais au banc une proportion une
proposition de loi ambitieuse visant à
renforcer les moyens de prévention et de
lutte contre les incendies ce texte est
aujourd'hui en lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale il est essentiel pour notre
avenir et nous l'avons examiné tout
lundi tout mardi et actuellement je
remercie Marc chéneaux qui est en train
de poursuivre cet examination qui cette
examen pardon qui s'opère de la façon la
plus on va dire constructive possible
les incendies que nous avons connues
l'été dernier qui frappent déjà des
Pyrénées-Orientales à l'heure où je vous
parle nous rappelle l'urgence d'agir
face à ces phénomènes amplifiés par le
réchauffement climatique et je profite
de votre question pour rappeler
l'engagement de nos sapeurs-pompiers
professionnelle ou volontaire et je
tiens à leur apporter à votre nom à tous
tout notre soutien concernant le sujet
spécifique du bois mort aucune règle
européenne ne s'oppose de manière
générale sur une parcelle forestière à
l'enlèvement de ce bois mort dans une
logique de prévention des incendies
tout particulièrement cet aspect revit
même un enjeu important dans la
prévention des feux de forêt et dans la
limitation de leur propagation la
réglementation dite habitat appliquée
par l'article
l401-1 du code de l'environnement
empêche pour sa part la destruction de
l'habitat d'une espèce protégée ce point
précis n'empêche pas l'enlèvement du
bois mort sur une parcelle alors en ce
sens la réglementation européenne
actuelle et la réglementation dite
habitat nous semble concilier le double
enjeu de préservation des habitats et de
la biodiversité d'une part mais aussi de
prévention et de lutte contre les
incendies je vous remercie je suis
ouverte à tous échange sur ce sujet je
vous recevrai bien volontiers sur ce
sujet sur lequel on travaille déjà
depuis plusieurs mois ensemble merci
madame Dugon
oui madame la ministre j'entends votre
réponse qui se veut rassurante en
revanche moi je vous parlais de d'un
texte à l'étude actuellement en
commission Environnement du Parlement
européen et ma volonté est de vous
alerter justement contre un règlement
qui s'il s'applique aura des
conséquences très graves pour nos
massifs forestiers et bien sûr la
mission de nos soldats du feu merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est de notre collègue Olivier
Hainaut pour le groupe de l'Union softry
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de la ville et
du Logement j'espère ne pas trop
contrarié madame la ministre qui vient
de s'exprimer précédemment elle concerne
le fameux DPE je n'aime pas les
acronymes mais il faut aussi faire des
PE diagnostic de performance énergétique
j'associe à ma question Jean-Michel
Arnaud sénateur des Hautes-Alpes très
investi sur cette question monsieur le
ministre je ne remets pas en cause la
bonne intention originelle du DPE mais
depuis Bernard de Clervaux nous savons
que l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions peut-être allez-vous nous
convaincre mais nous voyons de nombreux
inconvénients à cette mise en place
précipitée du DPE je cite les délais
très contraints pour la réalisation des
travaux et donc le renchérissement des
coûts la question du de poids de mesure
entre les petites surfaces et les grands
logements
son caractère uniforme jacobin vertical
et descendant on a malheureusement
l'habitude qui n'indique pas les
variations qui ne tient pas en compte
qui n'intègre pas les variations
climatiques et c'est un homme du Nord
qui parle et enfin ces conséquences sur
l'offre de logement combien de logements
vont disparaître de l'offre de location
au moment même où se profile une crise
du logement sans précédent monsieur le
ministre chers collègues pour conclure
vous l'avez compris pour nous le DPE
comporte des germes de fractures
sociales et territoriales et donc ma
question est la suivante comment
voyez-vous la mise en oeuvre du DPE sont
calendrier et ses conséquences sur la
crise du logement qui se profile je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
en charge du logement merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Olivier Hainaut oui le DPE est
utile le DPE a été réformé pour être
plus en phase avec la réalité de la
qualité des logements et il y a
effectivement une crise du logement mais
cette crise du logement ne doit pas nous
laisser entendre qu'on peut laisser
vivre nos concitoyens dans des passoires
thermiques le calendrier tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui il concerne d'abord
pour le 1er janvier 2025 les plus les
passoires thermiques les plus
importantes à partir des étiquettes g
puis 2028f etc les propriétaires
bailleurs comme les propriétaires
occupants sont accompagnés et
connaissent cette évolution depuis de
nombreuses années d'ailleurs les
propriétaires bailleurs continuent à
percevoir un loyer et pour ma part et je
crois que c'est notre proposition à tous
on ne peut pas fait des habitants vivre
avec des enfants dans des passoires
thermiques dans le fait qu'elle il fait
très chaud l'été très froid l'hiver dans
lequel il y a de la moisissure sur les
fenêtres et c'est le sens de cette
mesure le gouvernement agit à travers la
mise en place de France raynove à
travers la mise en place des cette année
des accompagnateurs rénov à travers ma
prime rénov qui se développe notamment
ma prime rénov sérénité qui doit
accompagner les plus fragiles à travers
le doublement du déficit foncier qui va
permettre aux propriétaires bailleurs
d'être encore mieux accompagné dans leur
travaux et donc toutes ces mesures mises
bout à bout doivent permettre de tenir
ce calendrier parce que ce calendrier il
est dans l'intérêt de ceux qui vivent
dans les passoires thermiques notamment
les plus fragiles de nos concitoyens
ensuite je n'ai pas un certain nombre de
particularités qui doivent être regardés
notamment dans les territoires de
montagne ou dans un certain nombre de
cas et c'est aussi pour ça qu'il faut
travailler à la rénovation thermique de
l'habitat collectif parce que bien
évidemment un propriétaire qui a son
appartement classé j'ai dans un immeuble
dans lequel on n'aurait rien fait et
bien se retrouver en situation
d'impossibilité de faire et c'est
l'obligation qui nous est donnée c'est
de mieux accompagner l'habitat collectif
dans ces travaux de rénovation je vous
remercie
monsieur etno oui perplexe monsieur le
ministre nous sommes perplexe par
rapport à cette nouvelle forme de jeune
homme donc je suis et j'ai peur qu'il en
soit du DPE comme des portiques de la
taxe carbone du ZFE ou de main d'usane
enthousiasme initial perplexité lors de
la mise en œuvre et abandons en race
campagne à l'approche du mur de la
réalité je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres nos prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le
mercredi 24 mai à 15h je vais suspendre
la séance elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour
l'examen de la proposition de résolution
en application de l'article 34-1 la
Constitution relative à la
reconnaissance du génocide ukrainien de
1932-1933 la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre sur public Senna une
séance mouvementée aujourd'hui il y
avait un élément central aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle que beaucoup ont
directement interpellé cette personne
c'est Yannick Morez mère de Saint-Brevin
vous le savez il était auditionné ce
matin par la commission des Lois du
Sénat suite à l'incendie criminel dont
il a été victime et qu'il a qu'il a
conduit donc à démissionner il y a
quelques jours et donc beaucoup de
questions aujourd'hui destinées au
gouvernement ont concerné son agression
la première d'entre elles venant du
président du groupe socialiste Patrick
Kanner qui n'a pas hésité à souligner
des dysfonctionnements graves de l'État
dans cette affaire écoutez-le
Saint-Brévin c'est aussi le signe d'une
résurgence des violences de l'extrême
droite depuis plusieurs semaines ces
actes de terrorisme intellectuel et
physique se sont multipliées pour
empêcher les mers qui le veulent de
prendre part à l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile madame la Première ministre on
ne peut mettre sur un pied d'égalité
l'extrême droite et d'autres formes de
contestation l'extrême droite que ce
soit au sein de nos institutions ou dans
le cadre d'action clandestine et
l'ennemi mortelle de notre démocratie
l'État ne peut rester larmes aux pieds
face à ses menaces allez-vous engager ce
combat pour défendre les élus de la
République une question pendant laquelle
Patrick Henner s'est également référé à
l'agression subie par Jean-Baptiste
trogneux petit neveu de Brigitte Macron
qu'il a évidemment condamné la première
ministre à elle voulut assurer le
soutien de l'État à tous les élus
les mers sont en première ligne sur le
terrain ils sont les premiers témoins de
la montée de la défiance dans notre
société nous devons les protéger nous
devons protéger tous les élus mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs il n'y a pas
de démocratie sans respect des élus pas
de démocratie sans sécurité pour les
élus avec vous tous avec le gouvernement
nous continuerons à agir je vous
remercie
Elisabeth Bank qui a conclu en
expliquant que les leçons avaient été
tirés et que Dominique fort ministre
délégué en charge des collectivités
territoriales qui a été une protagoniste
importante aujourd'hui ferait des
annonces ce soir à ce sujet après le
rendez-vous à Matignon avec Yannick
morestan merci merci à beaucoup Mathias
pour ce retour sur ce temps fort de
cette séance de questions au
gouvernement ayant poursuit tout de
suite le débrief en allant ça la
déconférence on a retrouvé Quentin
Quentin qui se trouve avec Christophe
déchu le ministre de la transition
psychologique et de la cohésion des
territoires voilà l'autre grand
protagoniste avec Dominique Faure qui a
répondu à 5 questions aujourd'hui lors
de cette séance Monsieur Béchu on voit
cette indignation générale au Sénat
après notamment l'Audi sur le ce matin
qui se tenait en commission des lois il
n'aurait pas de honte à reconnaître que
l'État dans cette affaire n'a pas été à
la hauteur c'est ce que vous avez
appliqué Roland dans tech pourquoi ne
pas le dire tout simplement tout
simplement parce que cette séance de
questions au Gouvernement elle
intervient quelques heures après qu'il
Yannick Morez ce soit exprimé devant le
scénar il s'exprimera devant la première
ministre à la fin de l'après-midi et
donc je respectais évidemment je ne mets
absolument pas en cause ni sa parole ni
son audition devant le Sénat je dis
juste que il me semble important à un
moment un autre qui a un autre son de
cloche et qu'on en entendante plusieurs
avant de se prononcer si il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements je n'aurais aucun
état d'âme à reconnaître qu'il y a eu
des dysfonctionnements j'ai été maire
pendant 10 ans donc vous savez un jeu
les agressions les insultes les tracts
anonymes les intimidations je sais ce
que c'est
j'ai été président de mon département
pendant 10 ans donc j'ai vu ces
violences auprès de d'autres et dans ce
domaine il faut évidemment la
condamnation la plus totale la fermeté
la plus grande et les mesures qui seront
présentées un peu plus tard dans
l'après-midi vous avez entendu le récit
du maire de Saint Brévin on a trouvé
qu'il a été un peu laissé en race
campagne par le préfet le sous-préfet la
procureur de la République c'est pas
l'impression que vous avez lorsque vous
entendez son témoignage quand j'entends
son témoignage c'est évidemment
l'impression que ça donne les
informations
dans cette affaire d'abord ils s'en
rendent vous savez cette véritablement
une des professions dans lesquelles on
rend le plus souvent des comptes puisque
on a un CDD d'une semaine qui
renouvelable tous les mercredis de
conseils des ministres en conseil des
ministres et pour être encore plus
complet avec vous les retours que nous
avons eu c'est qu'il y a des patrouilles
de gendarmerie qui sont faites devant
son domicile dans les jours qui suivent
que la gendarmerie s'est rendu chez lui
pour lui proposer un accompagnement qui
a eu des prises de contact par la
préfecture donc je remets pas en cause
son témoignage ça ne correspond pas à
une partie des messages qui m'ont été
donnés par les services donc c'est pour
ça que dans ces conditions ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'on prenne le temps
dans un process contradictoire classique
d'entendre les deux versions et si à la
fin il y a des dysfonctionnements je le
redis il s'agit pas de protéger qui que
ce soit il s'agit très clairement de
faire la lumière pour deux raisons
d'abord pour lui rendre justice à lui
mais ensuite pour savoir comment
collectivement ça ne se reproduit pas
ouais justement comment aller plus loin
on voit Dominique fort qui va installer
ce centre d'analyse sur les violences
faites aux élus elle dit qu'il faut
amplifier ce que nous faisons je cite et
elle parle elle explique aussi qui
pourrait avoir des peines alourdi sur le
mode et bien du fait que si on s'attaque
à un maire on s'attaque aussi comme un
force une force des gens de défense de
l'ordre c'est Seb une piste qui
envisageait ce qui est sur la table ça
je vous confirme il y a plusieurs
aspects il y a un aspect qui est de
mieux connaître parce que on en parle
finalement quand il se passe quelque
chose mais il y a tout ce qu'on ne voit
pas et qui donne lieu parfois à des
mains courantes à des dépôts de plainte
comment est-ce que on coordonne d'abord
les réponses comment on a une meilleure
grille d'analyse et comment on fait en
sorte d'avoir une forme de fichier qui
permettent de suivre et d'accompagner
tous ceux qui sont concernés deux des
référentes proximité
3493 dans les gendarmeries et les
commissariats de police avec l'idée
qu'on puisse binomer en quelque sorte un
maire avec un lieu qui abrite des forces
de l'ordre pour qu'ils dispose d'une
sorte de référence sécurité et 3 se
poser la question de la sanction pénale
en 2022
dans les chiffres que nous avons 2245
atteintes à des élus le 34% d'un an
exactement 945 sanctions pénales
c'est-à-dire qu'on a aujourd'hui 40% des
faits qui ont donné lieu à des
poursuites et à des sanctions et un
certain nombre de cas dans lequel pour
des actes anonymes pour des lettres
anonymes on n'a pas retrouvé
nécessairement les auteurs mais il faut
que ceux qu'on prenne
j'allais dire on fasse en sorte
effectivement de les punir et c'est ce
que vous décrivez de la même manière que
ceux qui portent l'uniforme
bénéficient en quelque sorte d'une
protection renforcée il faut qu'on
considère que l'écharpe de mer même si
elle est pas portée au quotidien elle
doit conduire à des peines à l'ordi
parce que c'est la République qu'on vise
et pas seulement en individu et bien
merci merci Christophe pour cette
réaction en direct micro Public Sénat
merci à vous merci merci beaucoup
Quentin on va consacrer l'essentiel de
ce débrief et bien à cette audition du
maire de Saint-Brevin qui a donné lieu à
de multiples questions tout à l'heure
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat et tout de
suite on va revenir ça des conférences
car le maire de Saint-Brevin Yannick
Maurice qui est reçu ce soir par la
première ministre qui a été auditionné
ce matin par le Sénat était tout à
l'heure au micro de Quentin
bonjour Yannick Morez merci d'accepter
d'y répondre aux questions de Public
Sénat effectivement on voit cette
ribambelle ce grand nombre de questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement aujourd'hui
qui vous concerne directement cet
hommage la standing ovation du Sénat
comment vous avez vécu à cette séance
alors c'est niveau fashion très
impressionnant c'est vrai que ça m'a
beaucoup touché
de voir en direct comme ça tous les
sénateurs se lever quel que soit en fin
de compte leur appartenance politique
c'est quelque chose d'impressionnant qui
montre en fin de compte que tout le
monde a été touché parce qu'il ce qui
m'est arrivé et donc c'est vrai une fois
de plus je remercie en fait tous les
tous les élus et bien de me soutenir de
cette façon c'est vrai que c'est une
journée
et qui n'est pas terminée
voilà
impressionnante ce matin c'est vrai que
de pouvoir raconter un petit peu tout ce
qui s'était passé c'était important pour
moi
après la décision que j'avais pu prendre
notamment de de démissionner et de tout
quitter
c'est une émission qui bien entendu qui
était pas facile à faire de démissionner
de tout quitter mais j'avais envie de
pouvoir continuer c'est vrai d'essayer
de faire passer un message justement sur
ce qui était arrivé pour éviter que ça
se reproduise que dire de la réponse de
l'exécutif c'est immédiatement la
question qu'on a envie de vous proposer
car il y a eu cette question mais c'est
cette réponse Dominique Farre qui dit
c'est inacceptable on ne laissera rien
passer on a entendu une réaction une
espèce de rumeur dans l'hémicycle à ce
moment-là c'est parce que peut-être que
il aurait fallu déjà ne rien laisser
passer avec ce qui vous êtes arrivé que
vous avez pensé de la réponse bah je
vais rencontrer tout à l'heure je pense
que même si je suppose qu'elle a eu un
compte-rendu de ce que j'avais dit ce
matin
c'est pas suffisant on a l'impression
qu'ils agissent une fois que c'est
arrivé or là en fait on avait quand même
alerté dès le départ tout ce qui est
arrivé et puis quand je l'ai présenté de
façon chronologique pour montrer que ça
monte avec crescendo et puis que malgré
tout ce qu'on a fait tous les courriers
qu'on a fait en fait on n'avait jamais
de réponse derrière
et qu'en fait c'est ce qu'on essayait
c'est ce que j'ai essayé c'est pour ça
que je continue là aujourd'hui pour faut
que ça change en fin de compte c'est
c'est avant qu'il faut agir c'est pas en
attendant une fois que le drame était
passé et dans les annonces qui vont
intervenir qu'est-ce que vous attendez
on voit ce centre d'analyse est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui vous intéresse
est-ce que des penalourdi au même niveau
que des forces de l'ordre c'est des
choses qui peuvent voilà changer la
donne dans ce que vous avez vécu vous
face à midi extrême droite alors le
centre on analyse enfin pourquoi pas
mais
en fait on voit très bien moi je reçois
depuis cette décision de très nombreux
messages et notamment de mère qui ont
subi aussi que ce soit des agressions
verbales ou physiques et qui n'ont rien
dit soit parce que en fin de compte en
disant en déposant plainte il n'y avait
pas de suite soit simplement parce que
ils savent que ça va pas aboutir et ben
ne faisait rien
donc ce centre d'analyses je pense que
ça va peut-être démontrer des liens un
peu les langues en fait ce que ce que
j'ai fait et puis peut-être également à
tout le monde du coup d'analyser en fait
tout ce qui s'est passé parce qu'il y a
sûrement des choses à faire et je crois
que les relations entre les d'une part
entre les élus les élus de base comme
comme les mers et puis les services de
l'État notamment avec les préfets c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut revoir à tout
prix il ne reste quelques secondes mais
vous allez à Matignon là dans les
prochaines minutes prochaines heures
quelle est votre message à Elisabeth
borne est-ce que vous attendez des
excuses de la part de la première
ministre au nom de l'État qui a été si
impuissant alors des excuses oui ma foi
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai démontré
qu'il y avait justement il y avait pas
eu de
services de l'État suffisamment
important pour pour m'aider malgré tout
ce que j'ai fait le sous-préfet la
procure la République voilà mais
maintenant c'est voilà c'est pour la
suite je crois que ça va être important
justement cette discussion il faut à
tout prix que quelque chose soit fait et
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé d'aller
jusqu'au bout pour pour l'avenir en fin
de compte pour mes futurs
collègues-mères et surtout si on veut
que la démocratie continue parce que
autrement 2026 on aura de moins en moins
de citoyens qui vont vouloir se
présenter aux élections municipales
merci juste un dernier mot vous ne
reviendrez pas sur votre décision votre
démission elle est elle est fermée
définitive elle est fermée définitive
bon et bien très bien et merci pour
cette réaction au micro public c'est là
aujourd'hui
merci merci beaucoup Quentin continue le
débrief sur ce plateau avec Martin de
fidrac bonjour vous êtes aussi natrice
les républicains des Yvelines et
vice-présidente de la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable à côté de vous
Bernard jaumier bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de Paris et
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales et enfin j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir Alain Richard
bonjour
sénateur RDPI du Val-d'Oise instinateur
Renaissance vice-président du Sénat
membre de la commission des lois Alain
Richard on entend le témoignage de
Yannick Morel qui s'est exprimé ce matin
devant la commission des lois une large
partie des questions gouvernement ont
été consacrées à sa démission à ce que
pour vous l'État a manqué assez de voir
face à la situation de ce maire
j'essaie de ne pas prononcer le jugement
en déficit d'information et d'ailleurs
je ne prononce pas beaucoup de jugements
je pense qu'il y a des institutions pour
ça
je pense que il y a en effet un flux de
d'actes d'incivisme et d'agressivité à
l'égard des élus comme elle garde
d'autres catégories de responsables et
que il faut s'assurer que la chaîne
d'enquête puis de jugement fonctionne
correctement dans un état de droit même
les coupables ont des droits et par
conséquent elle ne peut pas être
immédiat
mais si vous avez été frappé quand même
par le témoignage de ce maire qui est
quand même raconté
je suis membre de la commission des lois
je ne suis pas le moins assidu mais je
siais à ce moment-là la commission des
finances parce que nous légiférions en
commun sur une réforme donc j'ai pas
entendu monsieur Maurice directement
enfin j'ai pris connaissance évidemment
de ce qu'il avait rapporté
le nombre d'alerte qu'il avait essayé de
donner sur sa situation et l'absence de
réponse du préfet du sous-proprié le
point principal c'est l'enquête la
démonstration de responsabilité des
auteurs et le jugement
ce que je constate c'est que on fait des
hauts à l'heure actuelle des efforts
importants de moyens pour que la justice
j'étais triste j'étais atterré parce que
qu'est-ce qui nous a dit le maire de
Saint-Brevin il a dit l'État a failli il
a dit le préfet a menti il a dit le
sous-préfet n'a pas été à l'auteur de
ses responsabilités il a dit les
gendarmes sont restés passifs et tout ça
à cause d'un projet qui était voulu par
l'État et soutenu par l'État sur sa
commune
et ce qui m'inquiète particulièrement
c'est que j'ai écouté tous les ministres
répondent cet après-midi et je trouve
qu'il y a une forme de l'acheter dans la
parole et c'est ça qui m'inquiète c'est
à dire que je n'ai pas entendu une seule
fois un membre du gouvernement nommé
l'extrême droite jamais un ministre a
dit le RN mais jamais c'est l'extrême
droite qui est derrière cette attaque
c'est l'extrême droite c'est reconquête
c'est le RN etc
c'est qui ont été violents c'est eux qui
ont menacé c'est eux qui ont mis le feu
très probablement très probablement on
verra l'enquête on verra on verra
l'enquête mais comme Alain Richard vient
de mettre de dire il y a probablement
une faute professionnelle des gendarmes
mais un préfet qui ne dit pas la vérité
qui ment dans une affaire comme ça c'est
à dire que le maire nous dit très
concrètement le préfet a dit j'ai
organisé des réunions publiques il n'y a
pas de réunion je vous coupe parce que
on a isolé ce passage donc je vous
propose que on l'écoute et comme ça on
peut tous avec le même niveau
d'information revenir sur ce moment on
écoute ce moment de l'audition de
Yannick Morez
ce qui est désolant également quand vous
avez vu voir la communication du préfet
après après ma démission parce que je
m'attendais pas à ce que ça fasse des
remous des remous comme ça c'est
démission quand il dit qu'il a organisé
des réunions publiques
je sais pas de la part d'un préfet
mentir effrontément en public c'est
quand même important je sais pas il
représente l'État
il sait très bien qu'il a pas organisé
de réunions publiques on a toutes les
preuves celui de lui demander la date il
pourra pas en fournir il en a pas fait
mais parce que le premier reproche que
fait Yannick Morez à l'état c'est de ne
pas avoir voulu communiquer sur et bien
ce cada qui allait être transporté d'un
lieu à un autre sur sa demande il estime
que dès le début il a été lancée l'État
a clairement sauf à invalider les
déclarations du maire de Saint-Brévin ce
que personne n'imagine tout de même
notamment cette question de de ce qu'a
dit le préfet l'État n'a pas été au
rendez-vous et la question c'est
pourquoi pourquoi au fond alors que les
alertes ont été multiples il n'y a pas
une prise en compte réelle enfin c'est
quand même un maire qui est obligé de
quitter sa commune de démissionner de
quitter sa commune et c'est l'extrême
droite qui est responsable alors il faut
impérativement je ne sais pas je vais
attendre évidemment les annonces de la
première ministre elle nous a dit
qu'elle allait annoncer des mesures je
n'attends que d'une chose de la première
ministre c'est qu'elle soit à la hauteur
c'est tout et j'espère qu'elle va être à
la hauteur je ne peux pas espérer autre
chose mais qu'elle soit à la hauteur
dans la réponse c'est à dire qu'elle
nomme clairement ce qui s'est passé et
qu'elle annonce des mesures concrètes
pas uniquement le centre d'analyse pour
protéger les élus et pour arrêter cette
montée de la violence qui ne vient pas
et je termine là que de l'extrême droite
dans notre pays on l'a vu avec
l'agression scandaleuse une vœu du
président de la République qui a
probablement d'autres origines il y a
une montée de la violence mais il faut
que la Premier ministre prenne des
mesures des mesures vous êtes d'accord
avec cela il faut que la première mise
prenne des mesures il faut aussi
peut-être que l'État reconnaisse les
erreurs il faut aussi que on puisse
entendre le plus râpé pour tout vous
dire c'est l'émotion c'est la véritable
émotion que l'on ressent de ce maire
puisque il faut le rappeler peut-être
quand on s'engage en politique quand on
devient élu local on nous prête souvent
beaucoup de pouvoir mais en réalité on
s'engage pour remplir des devoirs
vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens et cette
émotion est réelle donc moi je souhaite
quand même avant de d'aller plus loin
puisque le sujet sera abordé rappeler
malgré tout que aujourd'hui nous vivons
quelque chose d'éminemment aigu mais ça
ne date pas que d'aujourd'hui
malheureusement on voit les chiffres ont
été rappelés à l'occasion d'une des
questions au Gouvernement d'aujourd'hui
2265 agressions en fait aujourd'hui qui
ne cesse d'augmenter cela potentiel cela
doit quand même nous alerter donc
au-delà de cette affaire éminemment
triste et éminemment forte
émotionnellement également pour ce maire
mais je savais que j'avais l'état
derrière moi
mais ce qui s'est passé là dans le cas
de Yannick Morez c'est que finalement ce
qu'il a bien expliqué ce n'est pas tant
la population avoisinante il y avait
bien sûr quelques résinois qui étaient
opposés mais c'est le fait qu'ils aient
puis pu rater aussi et bien l'extrême
droite des groupuscules extrêmement
violents qui sont venus sur le
territoire il y a eu encore une
dimension supplémentaire
de délit
d'infraction graves et qui seront
poursuivent malheureusement je crois que
parmi nos élus locaux au-delà de
l'étiquette politique et des positions
des uns des autres nous sommes en
démographie en démocratie cela se
respecte on voit qu'en réalité
l'étiquette politique finalement
[Musique]
ne fait plus tellement de différence on
a des élus de tout bord politique qui
sont agressés aujourd'hui menacées
par mes deux collègues il faut laisser
l'enquête se dérouler voire
véritablement où sont les
responsabilités pour moi il est évident
qu'après l'indignation et la
condamnation il faut que nous arrivions
à la sanction ça me paraît fondamental
sinon l'autorité dont on parle en creux
finalement c'est de ça dont il s'agit
aujourd'hui de l'État risque
véritablement d'apparaître encore plus
affaibli et ça ce message en creux d'une
violence qui ne serait pas punie qui ne
serait pas sanctionné et éminemment
important et grave aujourd'hui on
continue les réactions celles des
conférences toujours après et bien le
audition ce matin du maire de
Saint-Brevin la suite de questions qui
s'en sont suivies tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat et Quentin vous
êtes avec le sénateur Jean Raymond et
bonnet
effectivement on entendait en plateau
ces témoignages le fait qu'il y a comme
cela et bien des agressions dans tous
les départements vous le dites aussi
dans le vôtre c'est des choses qui vous
remontent des élus locaux il y a
maintenant au niveau de tension qui est
du jamais vu sur le terrain ben écoutez
moi j'ai pas attendu que ça me remonte
puisque je suis élu local depuis 2001
j'ai été 17 la mer de ma commune je suis
toujours au conseil municipal j'ai vu en
23 ans les choses se dégradaient de
façon constante et ne tournons pas
autour du pot si vous voulez bien parce
que j'entends des débats on essaye de
mettre un peu de politique ça n'a rien à
voir avec ça ça avoir avec le fait que
notre pays depuis longtemps n'est plus
gouverné et l'autorité est bafouée dans
ce pays nous ne prenons pas les mesures
qui s'imposent par peur par peur et
c'est justement uniquement dans le
témoignage aussi du mal à Saint-Brevin
on entend le fait que il a été un peu
laissé en race campagne par le
sous-préfet le préfet et on voit même
qu'il y ait une séance de question
d'actualité il y a un mois où les
sénateurs ont alerté le porte-parole du
gouvernement sur la situation dans la
commune et on se dit qu'il y a pas eu de
suivi c'est ça c'est la formation n'est
jamais remontée je ne vois pas je ne
vois pas l'information comme une série
télévisée rendez-vous compte que nous
sommes dans un pays dans lequel nous
avons tranché la gorge d'un professeur
que s'est-il passé après ça à part les
beaux discours à part les prises de
position la situation est grave dans
notre pays si on veut la voir en face on
prend les décisions qui s'imposent on ne
va pas faire à chaque fois des discours
enflammés disant que oui ah la la non on
connaît cette situation elle se dégrade
nous la vivons tous les jours et c'est
inacceptable dans ce cadre que penser de
la réponse de l'exécutif notamment lors
de cette question lors de cette sortie
la commission
Théodule les pennes alourdi ou autre
tout ça est du bavardage nous avons à
faire avec le plus grand respect pour
eux bien entendu il représente des
ministres de la République mais tout le
monde voit qu'ils sont totalement
désemparés et qu'il n'y a aucune réponse
effective et concrète apportée à cela je
le dis on a tranché la gorge d'un
professeur des écoles on agresse des
élus c'est la République qui est en
danger il serait temps de se réveiller
donc c'est par exemple le fait que les
juges ne vont pas assez loin dans les
peines qui sont c'est quoi votre réponse
vous à ce désordre les les décisions de
justice ne se commandent pas tout le
peuple français a compris ce qu'il en
était de la justice aujourd'hui quand
vous êtes le nom du problème quand vous
êtes c'est un des nœuds du problème je
vous l'ai dit c'est un problème de
République le jour où nous aurons un
pays qui sera gouverné nous viendrons
peut-être à bout de cela c'est
l'autorité qui doit être restaurée
partout et pas de façon sporadique et
bien merci merci pour cette réaction
merci à vous merci beaucoup Quentin on
entend la colère de Jean Raymond
Hugonnet on a aussi et bien entendu des
échanges enflammés tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle je vous propose notamment
d'écouter tout à l'heure l'échange entre
Ronan dans tax sénateur de
Loire-Atlantique et le ministre
Christophe Béchu
il est en tribune et c'est d'abord à ce
type que nous lirons hommage il tenait
bon face à la haine de l'extrême droite
et desire Éric Zemmour
mais je vous demande précisément
monsieur le ministre de répondre aux
interrogations de Yannick morrez nous
lui devons s'écarter première question
pourquoi Yannick Morel n'a-t-il pas fait
l'objet d'une protection rapprochée de
l'État depuis le mois de mars deuxième
question pourquoi avoir autorisé la
manifestation en kikada du 29 avril je
me réjouis que le Sénat au travers de
cette exemple d'un acte de courage
d'intimidation et d'un niveau de
violence qui a été franchi et qui a
atteint des paliers inacceptables
essayent de faire la lumière ce que je
souhaite dans le même temps y compris
compte tenu des retours que nous avons
c'est que vous en profitiez peut-être
pour demander aux forces de l'ordre à
ceux qui travaillent au sein de
Loire-Atlantique qu'elle a été leur
version de leur côté les retours qu'ils
ont eu
est-ce qu'il faut enquêter entendre
aussi et bien le préfet le sous-préfet
c'est ce que prévoit la commission des
lois sur lesquelles bien le maire a
quand même tiré à boule et rouges il les
a accusés de mensonges etc on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure oui bien sûr bien
sûr parce qu'on est en démocratie on a
une démocratie et que justement les
réponses à ces crises ne passent pas par
plus d'autoritarisme ça c'est un piège
ça c'est le chemin que veut l'extrême
droite ça c'est le chemin que veulent
tous ceux qui justement
procède à ces violences c'est affaiblir
notre démocratie et le problème
évidemment parce que c'est ancien moi je
vous partage ce qu'a dit aussi notre
collègue Hugonnet sur le fait que le
phénomène est ancien que il a il a des
racines qui sont multiples
il y a un contexte politique qui est un
contexte de grande tension l'essuie de
la réforme des retraites on peut
remonter plus en amont est-ce que notre
pays peut encore avoir des alternances
beaucoup de gens se posent la question
la bouleversement du paysage politique
qui fait que le chef de l'État élu à
chaque fois dans un duel face à un
extrême en l'occurrence à Marine Le Pen
pose la question à tous ceux qui sont
dans le champ de républicain savoir si
il peut y avoir les alternances la
constitution de la 5e République a été
faite pour cette un peu cette alternance
de deux blocs et ça ne fonctionne plus
et donc c'est un impact aussi mais c'est
un mélange c'est évidemment il y a pas
civique une crise institution
il n'y a pas un facteur il n'y a pas un
responsable faut être clair mais il y a
tout un contexte qui fait que tout ça
progresse et dans ce contexte l'extrême
droite en l'occurrence puisque c'est
bien d'aide dont il s'agit à
Saint-Brévin poussent les feux comme
elle le pousse régul
c'est ce que sont les devoirs
Elisabeth borde on va recevoir tout à
l'heure Yannick Morez qui a très
clairement
remis en cause le préfet le sous-préfet
la procureur de la République le Sénat
veut entendre tout le monde c'est
important dans le contexte actuel il
faut faire la lumière et sanctionner
je crois pas qu'on puisse sanctionner un
procureur
une petite thématique qui s'appelle la
séparation des pouvoirs et indépendance
de justice non je prends ça je prends ça
sérieusement
l'enquête doit être complète et c'est
clair que j'ai de la gravité de cette
atteinte parce que là
même dans le cas de signe ou le collègue
a été tué Michel le maire de signe en
pour tuer la personne alors que là
évidemment les auteurs de cet acte son
problème directement à la personne ça
m'est arrivé dans une affaire de tout à
fait de droit commun d'avoir ma maison
incendie alors que j'étais dedans c'est
évidemment ça fait ressentir quand même
une menace donc c'est un procès criminel
d'un côté et de l'autre côté c'est une
enquête administrative sachant que quand
même dans mon expérience qui commence à
être assez large chaque fois qu'il y a
une menace sur les élus le préfet se
mobilise le commissaire de police ou le
commandant de gendarmerie organise
quelque chose pour accompagner la
personne bon des limites aussi la
tranquillité privée de l'élu que pour la
charge des services à chaque fois
quelque chose est fait donc vraiment il
me semble qu'il y a quelque chose
d'anormal dans ce cas-là
normal dans sa situation c'est vraiment
la suite
du gouvernement que j'avais encore la
responsabilité de la gendarmerie
on mobilisait quand même moi
particulièrement inquiétant c'est que à
chaque fois nous en parlons lorsque
l'effet graphe se produisent or des
signaux il y en a depuis pas mal de
temps permettez-moi d'insister je ne
partage pas tout à fait ce le discours
de mon collègue Pierre gemier simplement
pas pourquoi parce que le sénateur
Richard a rappelé que ce soit pour des
raisons politiques que ce soit pour des
raisons tout à fait involontaire nous
avons aujourd'hui des élus qui vivent
des choses difficiles dans leur
territoire et nous avons même des élus
qui aujourd'hui ne déposent même plus
plein ça il faut le dire il ne dépose
plus plainte pour les mêmes raisons de
la consultation c'est exactement on ne
porte pas plaindre parce que nous sommes
découragés parce que nos plaintes ne
sont plus prises pour un tas de raisons
bonne et mauvaise je dirais mauvaise et
d'autres parts lorsqu'elles sont prises
il n'y a pas de suite donc comment
voulez-vous que dans ces cette espèce
d'ambiance nous puissions aujourd'hui
aller dire à nos élus et à nos mères
allez-y défendez la République vous êtes
les fantassins on vous adore et derrière
et ben on en parle là vous voyez autour
du plateau qu'est-ce qu'on va faire qui
ont qui est le coupable qui n'est pas il
y a des choses qui se sont passées avant
il a très bien dit
très clair là dessus
il faut que nous l'ayons en tête là
aujourd'hui c'est juste la partie
visible de l'iceberg de quelque chose
qui est là depuis des années depuis des
années et je crois que pardon
excusez-moi quand certains responsables
le politique se permettent de dire que
au fond quand on est quand il y a de la
violence de l'État on peut se permettre
d'être violent soi-même qu'on soit de
droite ou de gauche c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas accepter en république
je suis désolé allez autres réaction
soit la raison celle du sénateur
Jean-Michel Arnaud qui est au micro de
Quentin salle des conférences on vous
écoutez avec attention parce
qu'effectivement il y a cette difficulté
pour les mains de parler vous le disiez
dans votre département aussi dans les
Hautes-Alpes le fait de parler même à
son équipe au sein du conseil municipal
et donc vous avec votre double casquette
de président de l'AMF de ce département
vous avez mis en place une initiative
racontez-nous s'il vous plaît oui c'est
très simple ce que les collègues vient
d'évoquer c'est à dire ce malaise la
difficulté aussi pour un maire isolé
dans sa commune parfois un peu qui
s'isole au sein de sa famille parce
qu'il est compliqué d'évoquer sa
détresse ses difficultés sont mal être
devant son conseil municipal parce que
le maire c'est un peu le Superman de la
commune mais il est aussi père le maire
souvent et donc ou mère de famille et
compliqué d'associer les familles et
donc on se retrouve et ça a été dit par
le maire de Saint-Brévin ce matin
lorsqu'on l'auditionné oui un détresse
psychologique oui un besoin d'accommande
d'accompagnement psychologique et donc
depuis des mois nous travaillons avec
l'Association des Maires des
Hautes-Alpes à la mise en place d'une
cellule d'écoute donc nous avons
conventionné l'Association des Maires
des Hautes-Alpes avec un psychologue
avec un 06 disponible que j'ai diffusé à
tous les maires des Hautes-Alpes pour
que il puisse mobiliser ce numéro pour
pouvoir parler pour pouvoir verbaliser
la difficulté c'est évidemment un
complément au travail que l'État doit
réaliser que la justice que la
Jean-Louis doit réaliser mais c'est un
sujet important accompagné
psychologiquement les mers est-ce qu'il
y a eu des besoins des maires qui en ont
fait usage depuis vous l'avez mis en
place mais c'est pour récent puisque on
voit bien il y a 10 ans vous voyez mais
la société évolue on mettait en place
une assistance juridique maintenant mais
une assistance juridique psychologique
au maire pour pouvoir accompagner les
maires dans leur activité dans leur
métier dont je pense que c'est une
initiative qui est importante nous nous
y travaillerons au sein de la mission
d'information sur dans la commune et du
maire et je pense auditionner ce matin
avec la commission des lois le maire de
saint-bré absolument et le maire a bien
indiqué tout le processus au cas il a
été confronté avec la difficulté
d'écoute qui ont été rappelés longuement
mais je crois aussi un accompagnement
psychologique nécessaire pour que les
maires ne craquent pas pierre
personnellement parce que il doit
pouvoir affronter la difficulté
l'adversité mais ils ne doivent pas être
détruit psychologiquement dans
l'exercice de leur fonction merci et
votre mission elle rendra son rapport à
quel moment là je pense qu'au mois de
juin le rapport sera rendu avec des
recommandations et bien on sera ça de
très près sur plus que c'est la Merci
Merci à vous merci Quentin on entend
donc voilà des dis
positifs Pan
iers et tout à l'heure la ministre
Dominique Faure a également parlé d'un
autre dispositif pour accompagner les
élus on l'écoute on va vous écouter et
ça dans l'esprit de ce qu'a dit
Christophe Béchu tout à l'heure de
toujours s'améliorer oui on va
s'améliorer de ce que vous allez nous
dire Monsieur le Maire et de votre
perception de cette inaction perçue par
vous mais je voudrais juste citer un
point un point
ça s'appelle l'alarme élu c'est 3000
référents dans la gendarmerie et dans la
police nationale qui seront dès le début
de la semaine prochaine investis de une
extrême proximité ce sera des référents
violences aux élus ça a été décidé par
le début de la semaine par Gérald
Darmanin
à la Richard votre réaction voilà ce
qu'annonce Dominique Faure c'est l'un
des points qu'elle va annoncer et bien à
la suite de la démission du maire de
Saint-Brévin c'est à la hauteur en tout
cas c'est un outil
utile parce que il y a tout un tas de
situations dans lesquelles l'élu hésite
porte plainte ou pas plainte il peut y
avoir des cas dans lesquels on le
dissuade de porter plainte et moi je
suis tombé là dessus je dois dire avec
étonnement il y a 7 ou 8 ans quand
j'étais encore à la délégation
collectivité locale on avait déjà eu une
réflexion là dessus et j'avais demandé
ce que j'avais été chargé rapporter
là-dessus ce que le ministère n'a juste
avec avec statistique sur les mises en
cause des la réponse était on en a pas
parce qu'on ne fait pas de catégorie
dans nos analyses de criminalité on fait
pas de catégorie de ce type parce que ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas une profession
juridiquement protégée comme les les
personnes détentées sur l'autorité
publique et depuis lors d'ailleurs ça
m'arrive assez souvent d'astic les
gardes des soutiens c'est primaires
disons est-ce que vous avez un système
statistique maintenant plus cohérent qui
permet quand même d'orienter l'action
des services et de faire des priorités
donc il me semble que ça fait de
détection des situations faibles ou le
maire appelle son correspondants police
ou gendarmerie et lui demande conseil et
le dit correspondant pourra vérifier
ensuite si ses collègues font bien le
travail d'enquête ou d'accompagnement
qu'est-ce qu'il faut prévoir pour
Bernard jaumier quel sont pour vous les
les premiers dispositifs à revoir
aujourd'hui quand on voit et bien la
situation de Saint-Brevin car des
dispositifs législatifs il y en a eu il
y a eu récemment la loi Delattre qui
permet aux associations d'élus de se
porter participe il y a eu la loi
engagement et proximité qui a écrit les
pouvoirs de police du maire qui leur a
apporté la protection fonctionnelle il y
a eu toute une mission toute une
consultation des maires après la mort du
maire de signes il y en a eu des choses
qui ont été fait par le Parlement et on
en est encore là oui et je partage alors
la proposition enfin d'ordre technique
qui est importante que à la Richard a
soulevé mais je crois que si on en a
d'abord il faut être efficace ça c'est
la première chose et enfin sortir de
c'est quand même de ces discours à
répétition qui ne produisent rien mais
la réponse elle peut être que politique
au fond au fond c'est pourquoi qu'est-ce
qui ne fonctionne qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne mal dans notre démocratie
mais je redis que ne soyons pas non plus
catastrophique nous sommes une
démocratie regardons l'état de la
planète notre pays est une démocratie
mais il y a quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne plus bien il y a quelque
chose entre le peuple et ses
représentants qui est grippé il y a une
manière de mener des débats nous sommes
tous élus depuis un certain temps ici
nous avons tous une expérience les
débats se sont
je peux pas employer un mot trop complet
trop trop fort mais j'irai utiliser en
tout cas ils sont devenus plus peut-être
plus plus tendu plus plus violent plus
plus fort et nous donnons cet examen
mais oui souvent que les débats
de mes amis mais moi je suis un je ne
sénateur en termes d'ancienneté ça fait
5 ans que je suis sénateur mais j'ai
quand même vécu ces derniers mois au
Sénat pour la première fois j'ai vu des
sénateurs hués d'autres sénateurs dans
l'hémicycle je n'avais jamais vu je ne
dirais pas qui peu importe mais je
n'avais jamais vu depuis que j'étais là
cette chambre à une tradition et
heureusement qui est toujours là
d'urbanité mais c'est la marque je crois
c'est un dé révélateur aussi de cette
tension politique et l'attention
politique ça se gère de façon politique
évidemment le chef de l'État est la
responsabilité le gouvernement en a une
et l'opposition en elle il faut trouver
les voies pour un nouveau dialogue
démocratique pour apaiser les tensions
pour apaiser la situation sociale sinon
sinon c'est clair c'est l'extrême droite
très probablement qui finira par imposer
sa façon de voir
je pense aussi qu'il ne faut pas perdre
de vue qu'il ne faut pas affaiblir nos
mères parce que c'est ça aussi qui est
un petit peu en train de s'installer
c'est que à travers un certain nombre de
prérogatives et de compétences qu'on ne
leur a enlevé sur des choses même des
sujets techniques du certaine manière
parce que qu'est-ce qui se passait dans
nos communes en fait vous étiez
administrés vous aviez une difficulté
vous adressez à vos élus le maire qui
vous disait vous faites ceci je peux
vous aider en cela etc aujourd'hui
lorsque cela arrive les mères ne savent
plus répondre à leur administrer cela
crée ça rejoint ce qui se dit aussi sur
ce plateau le maire aujourd'hui n'est
plus perçu comme la ressource pour nos
concitoyens et ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose qui est fondamental il
faut que nous ayons également en tête
donc rendons un tout petit peu plus je
dirais de pouvoir d'une certaine manière
à nos territoires et aux élus des
territoires de manière à ce que la
décentralisation
certes de la décentralisation exactement
qu'à ce moment là les mères eux-mêmes
soient un peu plus en capacité de
pouvoir répondre directement alors
concitoyens je crois que c'est
fondamental dans notre démocratie cet
aspect là qui ne faut pas qu'on oublie
et bien merci merci beaucoup à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à se débrief des
questions au Gouvernement la démission
du maire de Saint-Brevin son audition ce
matin et bien on va encore en parler à
18h dans le sens public avec Thomas Hue
gain qui consacre son débat d'actualité
à ce sujet mais auparavant et bien je
vous propose tout de suite et bien de
revoir cette audition qui a eu lieu ce
matin au Sénat l'audition de Yannick
Morel donc le maire de Saint-Brévin qui
a démissionné la semaine dernière après
avoir été menacé après avoir vu sa
maison incendiée place donc à cette
audition
on va commencer par remercier en fin de
compte tous les messages de soutien que
j'ai pu avoir de tous les élus de France
en quelque soit le rôle
ça apporte beaucoup de chaleur c'est
vrai
je me suis aperçu qu'en fin de compte
dans tous ces messages d'élus que j'ai
reçu j'ai reçu par rapport à la date de
l'incendie par rapport au 22 mars où
j'avais déjà reçu beaucoup de messages
de soutien beaucoup plus de messages
notamment de soutien de merde qui m'ont
exprimé également ce qu'il aurait été
arrivé et notamment parfois les
agressions qu'elle soit verbale ou
physique et puis qui n'ont en fin de
compte n'ont rien fait non pas non pas
déposé plainte puisque à chaque fois
c'est ce qu'il me mettait dans les
courriers que j'ai reçu très souvent ça
terminait sans suite voilà donc en fait
c'est vrai que quand on voit le chiffre
important là et notamment l'augmentation
importante des agressions depuis un an
je pense que ce chiffre est largement
sous-estimé
évaluer puisque dans les dans tous ces
courriers on s'aperçoit quand même que
c'est c'est relativement très souvent et
puis c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
pas terminé avec toutes les contraintes
que nous avons nous a subir les maires
avec les différentes lois et je pense
que dans l'avenir et notamment avec la
loi résilience et notamment avec le zan
on sait très bien qu'on a des personnes
et des concitoyens qui ont acheté
parfois des terrains à transmettre pour
leurs enfants quand il faudra leur
annoncer que c'était un nœuds sont plus
constructibles qui est-ce qui va prendre